monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous accueillons monsieur le ministre
avec plaisir et beaucoup d'attention et
ce pour la troisième fois devant notre
commission
nous vous entendons aujourd'hui sur deux
thèmes importants le projet de loi de
programmation militaire qui va bientôt
naître je l'espère et bien sûr la guerre
en Ukraine et ses conséquences
concernant tout d'abord la LPM je
rappelle que le Président de la
République en a donné un certain nombre
d'orientation lors du son discours du 20
janvier dernier à Mont-de-Marsan mais
à ce stade de nombreuses interrogations
subsistent encore tout d'abord sur le
calendrier quand est-ce que ce projet
sera présenté devant le Conseil des
ministres et que reste-t-il à arbitrer
au cours des prochains jours des
prochaines semaines
ce que vous pouvez nous en dire sur le
fond ensuite le chef de l'État a annoncé
une enveloppe de 400 milliards d'euros à
laquelle viendrait s'ajouter 13
milliards de ressources extra
budgétaires ces montants disons-le tout
de suite sont importants et ils sont les
bienvenus bien évidemment l'effort réel
dépendra aussi de l'inflation mais
surtout ce niveau de dépenses
pourra-t-il nous permettre de faire face
à la montée des périls plus que jamais
les tensions se multiplient et nous
avons besoin de renforcer et de remettre
à niveau nos armées continuant en cela
la précédente LPM nous souhaitons par
ailleurs que cette LPM et son rapport
annexé soit aussi précis que possible
sur l'articulation entre le contexte
stratégique les contrats opérationnels
des armées les cibles en matière de
capacité de soutien de préparation
opérationnelle de disponibilité
on a eu l'occasion du reste déjà
d'échanger sur le fait que cette loi
devait être
ces éléments devaient être les plus
précis possibles pour permettre le
contrôle indispensable du Parlement
alors même que ces dernières années mais
vous n'êtes pas en cause nous avons
constaté une baisse de la qualité de
l'information dont dispose les
parlementaires en la matière donc nous
souhaitons jouer ce que j'ai appelé
carte sur table
l'effort annoncés dans les domaines
transversaux tels que le cyber ou le
spatial est évidemment indispensable
vous nous direz aussi là où en sont vos
réflexions enfin la guerre en Ukraine ne
doit pas être notre unique boussole mais
elle pose néanmoins un certain nombre de
questions quant à notre capacité à
affronter un conflit de haute intensité
nos armées ont été éreintés par 30 ans
de dividendes de la paix funeste
expression
par rapport à certains de nos
partenaires nous voyaient bien que nos
volumes d'aide à l'Ukraine ne sont pas
aussi extensibles que certains leur ai
souhaité
le récent rapport de nos collègues
Cédric Perrin et Jean-Marc Todeschini a
montré qu'il fallait remonter en
puissance dans le domaine des feux de
longue portée ainsi que sur les
munitions et la logistique n'ont pas
bien sûr parce que nous risquons d'être
envahi demain matin mais pour affronter
une dégradation du contexte géopolitique
dans toutes les régions du monde où la
France est présente et pour pouvoir
rester un allié exemplaire au cas où la
situation viendrait à se dégrader encore
en Europe malheureusement cette
hypothèse n'est pas totalement exclue
nous avons aussi un enjeu de puissance
nous voyons bien que l'effort de défense
considérables de la Pologne renforce
rapidement son poids politique en Europe
en particulier en Europe de l'Est donc
il y a maintenant une appréciation de
l'influence des pays en fonction de
l'effort qu'il concentre en faveur de
leur propre défense
monsieur le ministre on souhaiterait
enfin en savoir un peu plus sur le volet
normatif de la LPM je rappelle qu'il y a
le volet normatif et le rapport annexé
ils n'ont pas la même valeur juridique
et législative bien évidemment nous
osons espérer que cet aspect est bien
avancé
on se rappelle qu'à l'issue de votre
propos liminaire nous avions un certain
nombre de questions de rapporteur
budgétaires sur le projet de LPM et donc
on va essayer de procéder de la même
manière c'est-à-dire je vais vous
laisser prendre la parole pour
présenter dans l'ordre soit parler de la
situation en Ukraine j'allais dire
mettre ce sujet
en prologue si j'ose dire malgré le
drame que tout cela recoupe et puis
insister plus particulièrement sur la
LPM qui est une préparation au débat que
nous allons avoir dans les semaines et
les mois futures et donc après votre
réponse aux questions de nos rapporteurs
budgétaires nous enregistrerai les
questions les autres membres de
la Commission et donc cette la situation
en Ukraine et les perspectives pour les
mois et peut-être les années qui
viennent
mais avant d'aborder tous ces sujets je
voudrais que vous nous disiez un mot de
ce qui s'est passé hier soir à l'Élysée
où nous étions l'un derrière l'autre du
reste pour assister au discours du
président de la République avant son
voyage en Afrique et je voudrais que
vous nous disiez un mot des annonces qui
ont été faites par le Président de la
République lors de son discours sur
l'avenir de notre relation avec la fric
le président a évoqué en particulier une
transformation des bases des forces
prépositionnées dont les effectifs
seraient diminués qui seraient désormais
co-géré avec nos partenaires africains
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
de dire que dès aujourd'hui tout ça
suicide beaucoup de questions et pour ne
pas dire d'interrogations quand je ne
veux pas parler de doute
on est évidemment très attentif à ces
implantations et qui sont anciennes et
pour lesquelles la France a déployé
beaucoup d'efforts c'est notre présence
permanente plus discrète je rappelle
qu'elle est aussi une source de
protection pour les Français de
l'étranger qui vivent dans ces dans ces
pays et il y a déjà eu beaucoup de
déflation dans ce domaine donc vous nous
direz quelle est la vision
du président de la République et la
vôtre puisqu'il vous a rendu hommage
dans la réflexion qui le conduit à
revoir ce qui est une bonne chose
demeurant la présence de la France en
Afrique semi je vous donne la parole je
rappelle que nous sommes en audio
transmission comme ça qu'on dit pardon
en audio vision voilà
la parole est au ministre et à lui seul
merci monsieur le Président de
m'accueillir de nouveaux mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs devant cette
commission permanente du Sénat j'avais
indiqué ma prise de fonction ma
disponibilité évidemment pour le
Parlement général et peut-être encore
plus particulièrement pour le Sénat pour
tout autre raison que vous comprendrez
bien et donc effectivement c'est un
exercice à la fois large et redoutable
puisque par les d'Afrique du crâne de
LPM en une fin d'après-midi présente
évidemment un effort de synthèse donc on
pourra j'imagine pas tout traiter et en
même temps rappelez aussi à l'ensemble
évidemment des membres de la commission
que j'aurai l'occasion si vous en êtes
d'accord de revenir de nouveau devant
vous pour moi aussi mais si Dieu me
prête vie et de et de pour ceux qui
croient et de et de permettre de
présenter formellement évidemment la loi
de programmation militaire aujourd'hui
il s'agit de faire un point d'étape vous
dire aussi comment elle avance il y
avait invité qu'est-ce qui reste à
conclure et peut-être commencer par là
puis qu'au fond après la question
africaine ou les questions
ukrainiennes peuvent aussi
déroulé de cette affaire dire que le
calendrier est tenu puisque des
présentations des grands axes
stratégiques du président de la
République à Mont-de-Marsan sont suivis
un travail interministériel en cours en
lien évidemment avec les différents
assemblées parlementaires moi je vous
salue les deux rapports effectivement
qui ont été rendus par cette commission
d'une part sur un retour d'expérience
Ukraine d'autre part vous n'avez pas
cité monsieur le Président si vous n'y
autorisez de dire un mot tout à l'heure
sur le rapport sur l'Indopacifique parce
que il dit aussi des choses des
interactions avec nos outre-mer et je le
dis tout de suite nous sommes inspirés
des travaux de la commission aussi dans
cette dans cette maquette de LPM et de
dire que le Conseil des ministres amené
à regarder le projet de loi l'horizon de
fin mars début avril comme nous l'avions
indiqué publiquement et je crois que
vous échanges entre la Conférence des
Présidents et le ministre des Relations
avec le Parlement et la première
ministre font un atterrissage à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat je le
crois on met et en juin donc les
calendriers sont tenus et donc c'est
même peut-être une curiosité que de me
retrouver devant vous pour un projet de
loi qui juridiquement n'existe pas
encore mais dont politiquement il me
semble absolument indispensable que les
représentants de la nation puisse non
seulement avoir connaissance du
raisonnement et du contenu de cette
réflexion mais peut-être aussi encore
pour l'enrichir et le cas échéant avant
l'amendement formel la mandée peut être
aussi dans son esprit
j'assume aussi dans ce travail
préparatoire de redire à quel point nous
ne souhaitions pas de livre blanc déjà
parce qu'à chaque fois il a quand même
plutôt servi à masquer malheureusement
ou à déguiser ou à arranger des
diminutions de crédit budgétaire pour
faire dire des choses stratégiques au
final à des coupes budgétaires et que
d'autre part dès lors que le Président
de la République en tant que chef des
armées étaient reconduit dans son mandat
par les Français et au regard aussi de
la situation internationale il était
logique que nous ayons une méthode plus
plus intime mais en même temps qui nous
permet aussi de nous inspirer de ce que
le Sénat ou l'Assemblée nationale
peuvent produire par ailleurs vous
l'aviez dit Parlement n'est pas un rôle
n'a pas un rôle comme les autres et donc
de cela aussi vous vous y retrouverez je
le crois vos petits la troisième
particularité dans la construction
c'était le PM et ça pour le coup pour
avoir rencontré pratiquement
l'intégralité de mes prédécesseurs c'est
une nouveauté c'est que nous ne sommes
pas partis d'une courbe nous sommes
partis à la fois de quelques grands
retours d'expérience l'Ukraine mais pas
que l'Afrique et la lutte contre le
terrorisme ces dernières années mais pas
que regarder en face force et fragilité
notre modèle d'armée mais pas que et
surtout regarder évidemment les menaces
telles qu'elles pèse réellement sur la
nation française dans son ensemble pour
aujourd'hui mais aussi pour demain c'est
à dire en cas les menaces qu'on est
capable d'imaginer à l'horizon 2035 2040
peut-être au-delà mais enfin beaucoup
d'humidité aussi ne s'emparer de nous
dans la manière de construire cette
affaire ça veut dire qu'au fond les 413
milliards c'est un mur qu'on a construit
par le bas en regardant au fond
qu'est-ce qu'il faut réparer continuer à
réparer c'était le mot clé de la LPM
dans lequel nous avons que nous
connaissons encore aujourd'hui qui a été
votée par la législature précédente et
puis
et le quinquennat précédent et
évidemment de regarder un tout petit peu
quels sont nos besoins pour essayer de
se projeter je le dis puisque c'est
peut-être là un point de divergence que
je pourrais avoir avec certains
commentateurs ou même peut-être certains
rédacteurs c'est de nous comparer avec
l'Ukraine je pense qu'une puissance
dotée membre de l'OTAN à l'ouest en plus
du territoire de l'OTAN de prendre ce
qui se passe in extenso en Ukraine comme
modèle de référence pour nos armées ou
pour notre sécurité collective présente
un biais intellectuel qui polluent
nécessairement la copie la France c'est
la France ne cherchons pas la comparer
avec d'autres pays et même d'ailleurs si
on devait la comparer à la
Grande-Bretagne autre puissance dotée
membre de l'OTAN la Grande-Bretagne n'a
pas la même relation avec les
territoires d'outre-mer on pourrait se
comparer avec l'Allemagne qui n'est pas
une puissance de thé bref donc je pense
que chaque situation sécuritaire à ses
particularités et que il ne faut pas
chercher la facilité et je crois que
même qu'il y a un caractère absurde et
je l'avais dénoncé et je le refais à
nouveau devant vous à dire que et si
nous étions dans la même situation que
l'Ukraine nous n'aurions que X jour pour
notre artillerie ou x jour ou x semaines
devant nous pour nos chars pardon mais
c'est refaire revivre des débats que
cette maison a pu connaître dans les
années 60 quand Pierre Messmer ou Michel
Debré venait défendre la force de frappe
et la nécessité de la force de frappe
devant cette maison donc je pense que
pour le coup il faut se projeter
autrement pardon de le dire sans être
trop patriote mais entre Français sur la
réalité aussi de ce qui est de ce qu'est
la France ça veut donc dire aussi qu'il
y a plein de menaces qui ne sont pas
couvertes évidemment par la dissuasion
par notre modèle d'armée tel qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui parce que tout
simplement sous votre nucléaire des
espaces nouveaux de conflictualité je
vais y revenir se font jour c'est vrai
de l'espace c'est vrai les fonds
sous-marins c'est vrai du cyber j'aurai
l'occasion de le détailler dans un
instant l'autre particularité est
peut-être que là je je m'arret quelques
instants c'est que c'est le
programmation militaire on a essayé de
la construire avec des patchs des thèmes
au fond parce qu'il y a des choses qui
fonctionnent déjà bien peut-être pas
utile d'en pour aller trop longtemps en
tout cas pas cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle les deux vont vous le moment
venu avec le projet de loi on pourra y
passer du temps en tout cas sur ce qui
nous semble indispensable de faire
évoluer ou de ou de moderniser la
première des choses je l'ai dit c'est
notre disposition nucléaire un certain
nombre de sénateurs d'ailleurs m'avait
interpellé sur le sujet en disant au
fond on a une responsabilité
générationnelle la dissuasion que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui ce sont les
décisions qui ont été prises il y a
10-15 ou 20 ans et donc les décisions
que nous allons prendre maintenant vont
compter pour les générations futures
c'est vrai pour les vecteurs c'est vrai
pour les têtes c'est vrai pour une
partie des efforts d'investissement qui
sont faits pour les directions
d'applications militaires pour la Marine
nationale ou pour les forces à une
stratégiques et donc évidemment c'est un
effort important évidemment aussi
contrairement à quelques légendes qui
circulent ici ou là cela ne mange pas
l'essentiel des augmentations de cette
programmation militaire j'ai pu entendre
dire que la 413 milliards d'euros au
fond de se justifie que par les sommes
la dissuasion je donne pas les sommes
maintenant mais vous le verrez dans le
format Haddock qui nous permettra de
traiter de ce sujet que ce n'est pas du
tout le cas et puis peut-être je le dis
pour le sénateur Perrin avec amitié je
conteste la notion de Ligne Maginot pour
la dissuasion nucléaire puisque dans le
dans l'esprit populaire la ligne Maginot
c'est quelque chose d'inefficace or je
pense qu'au regard de ce que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui en Ukraine nous
voyons bien que cette dissuasion
nucléaire elle est efficace est-ce
qu'elle se suffit à traiter toutes les
menaces la réponse est non mais ce n'est
pas complètement la même chose mais on
aura pour le coup l'occasion d'y revenir
ensuite une vraie réflexion et sans
doute entre les différentes sensibilités
politiques et groupes politiques ici
présent au Sénat où nous n'aurions pas
tous la même approche et c'est normal
puisque c'est ainsi depuis aussi les
années 60 quelle est la dimension que
l'on a en souveraineté en autonomie
stratégique et donc aussi quelles sont
nos alliances je veux dire autrement
qu'est-ce qu'on veut à tout prix faire
seul qu'est-ce qu'on doit à tout prix
faire seul qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire
seul et bouleversement qu'est-ce que
l'on est prêt à partager c'est vrai des
capacités industrielles c'est vrai
également des certains instruments de
planification
ça pose des questions bien sûr de nos
élanse militaires l'OTAN multilatéral
les alliances militaires bilatérales
notre traité de défense sa pose aussi la
question de la coordination entre
l'Union européenne et l'OTAN j'ai pas le
temps mériter une séance d'audition
dédiée à ce sujet mais d'ailleurs je me
tiens prêt à le faire devant vous mais
il est clair que là ça pose de
véritables questions qui ont un
forcément un impact sur le modèle
d'armée je le dénonce notamment sur les
prises de position de la France
insoumise dans un autre hémicycle dans
une autre chambre ou au fond ou du
rassemblement national remettre en cause
purement et simplement l'appartenance de
la France à l'OTAN alors que la France a
fondé l'OTAN je rappelle quand même que
le général de Gaulle a pris des
décisions certes sur le niveau
d'intégration de la France dans le temps
mais là je trouve quelque chose de
curieux et pour le coup je rends hommage
aux rapports de du ministre ou tenez du
sénateur Perrin sur la nécessité
d'assumer cet appartenance à l'alliance
le dieu d'autant plus qu'une forme de
courage politique puisqu'on l'a bien vu
pendant la campagne présidentielle que
cette alliance militaire a fait l'objet
curieusement de remise en cause un peu
démagogique sur lequel je serai aussi
heureux évidemment de pouvoir reprendre
du temps il y a des recommandations qui
sont faites dans le rapport je pense que
certaines sont complètement couvertes
mais je peux répondre à vos questions
sur le sujet en tout cas nous nous
réinspirons de ce rapport sur cet aspect
des choses pour la LPM c'est absolument
clé la France n'est pas dans une île
dans un isolement stratégique et ça pour
le coup c'est absolument cardinal ça
permet aussi de se poser des questions
sur ce que l'OTAN ne doit pas / ne peut
pas traiter sur d'autres séries de
menaces ou d'autres zones géographiques
dans le monde et donc cela aussi si on
n'est pas clair sur le temps on n'est
pas clair sur le reste et donc merci
pour le travail qui a été fait ici
ensuite je le disais regardez les
menaces sous la voûte nucléaire qui
nécessite aussi des réponses
particulières ou quelles sont les moyens
conventionnels qui tiennent la voûte
nucléaire c'est parfois ça couvre pas
forcément les mêmes réponses mais
évidemment cette affaire se rencontre 1
évidemment la question du renseignement
le scénario longuement revenu nombreuses
reprises c'est vrai d'ailleurs pour les
trois services dont j'assure la tutelle
la DSD la moins connue mais
redoutablement d'actualité avec les
sujets d'ingérence de Contres espionnage
j'ai compris pour notre pays TD
évidemment la Direction du renseignement
militaire dont je tiens vraiment à
rendre hommage puisque entre les
constats qu'on peut être fait au début
des années 90 lors de la première guerre
du Golfe et les capacités souveraines
que nous avons aujourd'hui à comprendre
ce qui se passe sur un champ de bataille
il y a un bon en avant prodigieux qui a
été fait et ça il faut le saluer est-ce
que c'est suffisant la réponse est NON
et donc pour la DGE aussi l'ensemble des
efforts à accomplir pour le
renseignement monsieur le Président mais
monsieur la sénateurs devra être
largement revu à la hausse dans le cadre
de la prochaine LPM et donc ce chiffre
que je n'ai jamais encore donné
publiquement mais ça sera plus 60%
d'augmentation pour les trois services
de renseignement et je précise même que
pour la DGSE ce n'est pas que les sujets
immobiliers qui sont concernés par
l'augmentation je le précise
qui vont être évidemment dédiés dans la
copie que nous vous présenterons au
Parlement sur le renseignement ces clés
ces clés pour la dissuasion c'est clé
pour la lutte contre le terrorisme ces
clés pour la compréhension de ce qui se
passe dans la compétition du monde
d'autant plus que nous sortons d'une
longue période où l'essentiel de
l'actualité des services de
renseignement était tourné contre la
lutte ont été terreau et que désormais
évidemment on revient aussi
du renseignement dans un contexte
stratégique plus tendu évidemment cela
nous oblige le deuxième sujet sur lequel
j'aurais l'occasion de le présenter lors
de la LPM sont les drones sur lequel un
retard inacceptable avait été pris et
donc désormais il ne s'agit pas tant de
rattraper le retard je pense qu'on sera
en retard si on rattraper le retard
c'est plutôt de faire un saut de
génération technologique d'assumer notre
retard pour aller peut-être prendre le
rendez-vous qui suit pour 2030 2035
c'est vrai dans les airs c'est vrai pour
l'armée de terre c'est vrai pour l'armée
de l'air une somme de 5 milliards
d'euros sera dédiée au seul patch sur
les sur les drones et j'entends
également évidemment avancer sur la
question des munitions rodeuses j'avance
parce que sinon je vais prendre tout le
temps de parole comme il est clair que
c'est un sujet qui d'identifier
troisième sujet la défense sol R pour le
coup c'est un des grands rétextes de
l'Ukraine pardon mais c'est aussi parent
pauvre des diminutions de crédits
budgétaires de ces 15 ou 20 dernières
années et là pour le coup la dissuasion
nucléaire pouvait avoir bandeau en
disant on peut déshabiller la défense
solaire parce qu'elle a dissuasion pour
le coup je ne le crois pas la défense
solaire conventionnelle est liée à notre
dissuasion c'est vrai pour toutes les
couches de la lutte antidrone de la
courte portée plutôt gamme Mistral de la
moyenne portée plutôt gamme Mika jusqu'à
la haute portée plutôt gamme sante y
compris dans sa nouvelle génération pour
la fin des années 2020 là aussi un
effort important sera accompli quatrième
patch sur lequel le président de la
République souhaitera lui-même présenter
la copie de LPM parce qu'il y tient
beaucoup à titre personnels ce sont des
autres mères ça revient aussi au travail
qui a été fait dans le rapport
indopacifique peut-être que j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure sur vos sur
vos questions force française peut
indiquer française force armée de
nouvelles Calédonie
[Musique]
les trois volets sur le cyber le premier
c'est l'attribution des attaques une
forme de police judiciaire en quelque
sorte c'est-à-dire c'est pas le tout de
voir que l'on soit en fait attaquer mais
être capable de dire qu'il nous attaque
dit quelque chose la cybercriminalité
n'est pas la taxe d'un service étranger
attaquer un hôpital n'a pas les mêmes
conséquences qu'attaquer un service
public par exemple l'Office national des
anciens combattants ou d'attaquer
l'entreprise de labilité qui par exemple
aurait un lien que les dissuasion
nucléaire donc la question de
l'attribution de manière globale est un
sujet que doctrine et technique et de
ressources humaines absolument clé le
deuxième des sujets évidemment c'est
entraver c'est pas le tout de voir et de
subir encore faut-il pouvoir mettre fin
et la troisième fonction sur laquelle
j'accorde beaucoup d'importance c'est
contre-attaquer puisque là c'est la
notion de légitime défense cyber pardon
de vulgariser à l'extrême mais je pense
que c'est important parce que dans les
médias ou dans l'espace public le mot
cyber recouvre des réalités qui sont
parfois très différents donc en tout cas
là aussi j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
c'est un enjeu sur la ressource humaine
ça n'en joue pour nos écoles je veux
dire aujourd'hui vous sortez sortie de
Saint-Cyr vous n'avez pas de filière en
tant que tel sur la guerre électronique
ou sur le cyber et mieux que cela
Polytechnique pourtant la grande école
d'ingénieurs militaire dont j'ai la
tutelle pareil donc là aussi je pense
qu'il y a évidemment aussi un enjeu pour
fixer aussi un savoir-faire
international dans cette affaire dans
lequel il y aura une compétition entre
les nations sans y douter et donc là
aussi il nous faudra il nous faudra
avancer 6e patch les fonds marins li à
l'Outre-mer mais pas que on l'a bien vu
aussi c'est un des rétex de la guerre en
Ukraine être capable de protéger nos
intérêts quand ils sont sous les mers
avec des difficultés d'attribution
câbles sous-marins pas et plane
évidemment là aussi faire en sorte de
mettre fin à certains déni d'accès et
donc là ça pose la question de la guerre
des mines ça pose la question des
capacités de robots et de drones
sous-marins y compris sur des capacités
en eau très profonde jusqu'à 6000 mètres
donc jusqu'à 6 km là pour le coup on est
quand même sur des choses qui sont assez
inédites là aussi genre l'occasion de
développer la copie le moment venu le
spatial septième patch je le président
là aussi un retard important a pu être
pris alors il y a plusieurs sujets je
les lanceurs pas le temps de les traiter
il y a les sujets évidemment des moyens
que l'on met dans l'espace ou qui nous
intéressent depuis la Terre donc là
aussi c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait depuis
l'espace qu'est-ce qu'on fait vers
l'espace qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans
l'espace là aussi une copie ambitieuse
sera présentée le moment venu huitième
patch les Forces Spéciales elles sont
clés elles sont interarmées elles sont
premiers à marcher pratiquement dans
tous les contrats opérationnels y
compris diffusion nucléaires et dans
tous les scénarios on voit bien qu'on a
la chance d'avoir une richesse humaine
absolument fabuleuse et formidable avec
une aptitude au combat et un courage au
combat qui font franchement force
l'admiration et le respect de tous on a
encore trop de difficultés sur les
équipements individuels pas par manque
d'argent mais plutôt par problématique
administrative donc je vais régler
rapidement ces sujets mais aussi parfois
sur la disponibilité des moyens
notamment de transport c'est la question
de la difficulté des hélicoptères qui
est bien connu
ici dans cette commission avec est un
sujet évidemment pour les Forces
Spéciales neuvième patch les munitions
sur lequel l'occasion de revenir mais
qu'elle soit complexe qu'elle soit non
complexe ça revient au sujet de
l'économie de guerre ça revient au sujet
de relocalisation vous avez dû le voir
j'ai annoncé la relocalisation de d'une
filière poudre avec un Ringo à Bergerac
notamment pour les obus le premier
première décision concrète en acte sur
ce que j'appelle ou ce que présente un
public plutôt appelé l'économie de
guerre donc là aussi c'est un patch
important et puis enfin le dixième patch
c'est évidemment le soutien la
réparation continue dire quand une LPM
tout a été fait serait mentir et donc là
évidemment il y a des efforts importants
je peux pas ne pas citer le service de
santé des armées sur lequel il y a
beaucoup pas accomplir avec une feuille
de route dédiée sur le sur le sujet
c'est vrai pour les hôpitaux militaires
de campagne c'est vrai pour je veux moi
une stratégie pas hôpital j'ai compris
j'ai fait pause sur un certain nombre de
transformations sur un certain nombre
d'hôpitaux militaire en province parce
que je de véritablement avoir une
stratégie plus long terme donc
l'occasion de faire des annonces aussi
sur sur le sujet puis évidemment avec un
travail sur les ressources humaines ce
que je dis sur les soutiens et c'est ça
vous pour les soutiens pour le ska pour
le service des essences des armées pour
le SID et pour globalement toutes les
infrastructures alors monsieur le
Président on somme nous dans la
préparation de la LPM les moyens vous
l'avez dit
413 milliards d'euros de dépenses
militaires pour un besoin en ressources
de 400 milliards d'euros c'est la
première fois qu'on distingue les deux
chiffres puisque jadis comme les crédits
diminués évidemment assez habilement on
ne retenait qu'un seul chiffre moi j'ai
souhaité être précis puisque depuis
pratiquement toujours le ministère des
armées à ses propres ressources extra
budgétaires alors souvent on pense aux
sessions de l'immobilier on a tort en
fait figurez-vous que c'est le service
de santé des armées qui est le premier à
porter des ressources au ministère tout
simplement ce qui est une tarification
des de l'acte médical et que donc le
ministère évidemment perçoit beaucoup de
beaucoup d'argent pratiquement 3
milliards d'euros sur sur ce sol de
segment là que nous avons aussi un
certain nombre de ressources par
ailleurs et que globalement ces
ressources extra budgétaires pour la
période est évaluée à 6 milliards
d'euros sur la base des critères de la
LPM actuel on a pris le constater comme
un maire l'aurait fait pour son budget
prévisionnel on a pris le constater et
on a tout simplement repris les mêmes
ingrédients du constaté pour pour la
période à venir il y a évidemment les
reports de charge dont je ne doute pas
qu'il s'agira d'un sujet de conversation
et d'attention mais là aussi j'aurai
l'occasion de les arbitrages sont pas
complètement rendus mais genre
l'occasion de vous de vous le présenter
et les marges frictionnelles qui pour le
coup dépendent beaucoup de l'industrie
de défense puisque c'est aussi leur
marché exceptionnel c'est le report de
charge c'est ce que l'acheteur mais sur
la table la marche fictionnelle ce sont
les effets qui induisent les retards de
l'industriel si je devais le résumer de
manière un peu un peu un peu facile et
simple en tout cas c'est ce que ça veut
dire les chroniques annuelles
c'est-à-dire le rythme d'augmentation
pour aller jusqu'à
c413 milliards d'euros est en train
d'être défini j'ai donné un mandat à la
Délégation Générale pour l'Armement pour
regarder comment les différents
programmes atterrissent en autorisation
d'engagement ça c'est pas très compliqué
en crédit de paiement c'est-à-dire le
moment on a véritablement l'armement ou
les munitions donc là il y a un travail
redoutablement complexe et je vous
rendre hommage aux équipes de la DGA
pour le travail quels sont en train
d'accomplir sous pression de votre
serviteur parce que il y a un enjeu
aussi au regard des sommes importantes
de fiabiliser les délais mais aussi les
prix je considère que dès lors qu'on
augmente
un certain nombre de volumes en tout cas
moi j'ai appris ça en cours d'économie
il est normal qu'on ne contribuable et
la nation soit en droit d'attendre
quelques réductions de coûts unitaires
notamment sur des gammes de matériel
parfois où on était parti pour en
acheter moins je pense à certains avions
ou certains bateaux bah il est clair que
cette négociation là elle doit se faire
aussi pour ça qu'on a fait les annonces
du président très en amont et qu'on a
cette présentation du Conseil des
ministres à la fin du mois de mars début
du mois d'avril parce que moi je voulais
si ça change aussi à la négociations je
crois qu'il y a pas de raison que chacun
ne fasse aussi un effort en la matière
je le dis à la BTD et je l'ai dit à
chaque grand chef d'entreprise de la
BITD droit dans les yeux et puis ensuite
évidemment il faut s'agira aussi
d'ajuster tout ça en loi de finance
annuelle puisque si cette LPM a été
respecté à l'Europe monsieur le
Président mieux que ça à chaque fois on
y a rajouté de l'argent souvent cette
affaire passe un tout petit peu inaperçu
enfin en gestion de l'argent et rajouter
pour faire face aux éventuels les
imprévus j'aimerais faire peut-être une
deuxième annonce à la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense
c'est préciser que le Président de la
République est la première ministre
m'ont autorisé à sortir les dépenses
liées à l'aide militaire à l'Ukraine de
la LPM c'est à dire que y compris par
sincérité budgétaire par transparence
démocratique vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens la lot de programmation
militaire elle est là depuis la première
décidé par Pierre Messmer le général de
Gaulle et Michel Debré pour définir le
format de nos armées et donc l'aide à
l'Ukraine me semble-t-il doit sortir de
la LPM et c'est ce qui a été décidé par
le Président de la République et la
première ministre et donc on vous
retrouverez mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs la date d'Ukraine dans la
dualité budgétaire en plus de la LPM
mais ce qui permettra aussi de d'assumer
cette affaire là de manière beaucoup
plus transparente et de manière beaucoup
plus démocratique faudra aussi dire la
vérité parce que parfois on a donné du
matériel qui était finissant et qu'on va
remplacer par du matériel de nouvelle
génération donc on aurait quoi qu'il
arrive fait cette acquisition là mais à
chaque fois je vous ferai la
démonstration dans un rapport dédié si
vous en êtes d'accord de comment cette
aide militaire à l'Ukraine sa traduction
sur le terrain budgétaire en un mot
monsieur le Président toutes les lignes
de la LPM par rapport à celle de 2019 va
augmenter toute sauf une l'approvision
pour les Opex pour cause ce sont des
provisions et en plus barkhane s'est en
terminé pour toute cette tas de raisons
la question des OPEX mérite un
traitement différent mais là aussi
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir le temps
passe mais j'aurais pu vous parler de la
politique de ressources humaines du
ministère des réserves bref beaucoup de
sujets évidemment pourraient être traité
mais je je le ferai une autre occasion
enfin il y a deux autres chantiers qui
sont importants un chantier de
simplification de déconcentration et de
subsidiarité au sein du ministère des
armées je pense que notre modèle l'armée
ne n'a pas que n'a pas eu que des
difficultés budgétaires si vous le font
de ma pensée depuis 15 ou 20 ans aussi
des enjeux de simplification d'aucun
dirait c'est le problème des armées en
temps de paix sauf que c'est une armée
d'emplois qui s'est beaucoup déployée
par tant de paix et on le voit bien
aujourd'hui le niveau de confiance que
l'on doit donner à un chef de corps un
commande basée aérienne base navale ou
de régiment la capacité à lui
déconcentrer beaucoup plus de décisions
qui sont prises aujourd'hui par les
États majeurs à Paris et le faire
redescendre sur le terrain je le dis
d'autant plus au Sénat ou évidemment la
question de la proximité territoriale
est un élément clé mais c'est vrai aussi
pour ce ministère que je que je découvre
particulièrement Jacobins sur certaines
fonctions qui ne méritent pas de l'être
et inversement il faut être Jacobins
parce que ce sont les armées sur
certaines fonctions dans lequel il faut
d'assumer et donc j'ai donné mandat elle
est à major des armées mais aussi elle a
DGA pour la ministration de me faire des
propositions que je vous présenterai en
même temps que la LPM parce que les
circuits administratifs de décision
correspondent aussi aux efforts
budgétaires que nous pouvons faire et
l'autre chantier je le disais c'est
l'économie de guerre c'est absolument
clé j'ai parlé du mandat donné à la DGA
j'y reviens pas sur le stock sur les
délais sur les prix j'ai également nommé
Monique Legrand Laroche qui est notre
inspectrice générale pour l'armement en
mission particulière sur la question des
canons César et tout ce qui va autour
des canons César quand je dis qu'il faut
prendre des risques voilà un module un
équipement sur lequel je crois qu'on
peut prendre des risques puisque à
l'exportation je ne vois pas très bien
comment ils le connaîtraient pas une
forme de succès malheureusement si j'ose
dire dans les enfin malheureusement
heureusement du point du vent se place
dans les dans les décennies qui viennent
donc là je vois bien qu'il y a un
accompagnement au changement au sein de
Nexter que l'État doit accomplir et puis
Laurent que les billion bien connu
ancien en général pour l'armement
davantage du côté industriel pour
réfléchir et coordonnées à ce qui peut
être fait notamment sur les munitions
c'est vrai pour les obus de 155 c'est
vrai aussi pour certains petits missiles
je pense au Mistral sur lequel on a
besoin on a besoin d'avancer vous m'avez
ensuite interrogé monsieur le Président
et je termine par là sur la partie
normative
elle est pratiquement finalisée elle
doit évidemment partir au Conseil d'État
pour s'assurer de sa conformité
constitutionnelle évidemment pas de
grosses surprises sur les différents
articles qui seront proposés
associés le Parlement moi je souhaite
que on puisse écrire en toute lettre
dans la loi de programmation militaire
la méthodologie pour ne pas peut-être
revivre des incompréhensions pour le
dire pudiquement tel qu'elles ont pu
être vécues ici même lors de la LPM
actuelle et donc là aussi je vous ferai
une proposition qui sera dans le texte
initial sur la manière d'associer le
Parlement après évidemment libre à vous
de la monnaie de la renforcer au
contraire de l'assouplir si vous pensez
que c'est trop rigide mais je pense
qu'il faut il faut l'assumer je pense
qu'il en va de l'acceptabilité sociétale
des 413 milliards d'euros par ailleurs
et que l'affaire de la Défense nationale
mérite aussi un portage populaire de
l'ensemble de la nation et que donc plus
on rencontre y compris des difficultés
réelles mangent rencontrées parce que
tout ça n'est pas qu'une mercale plus à
mon avis on bâtit justement cet
acceptabilité les ressources budgétaires
et puis vous m'avez fait la demande à
l'instant d'un rapport annexé précis moi
je rajouterais précis efficace et je
rajouterais même que précis efficace ne
signifie pas forcément bavard et
technocratique pour être complètement
transparent j'ai fait cet exercice de
regarder les LPM depuis 1960 et en fait
je m'aperçois qu'en 2019 on a un
glissement vers un rapport annexé
particulièrement dense parfois très
technique qui correspondait aussi à
l'exigence politique du moment
c'est-à-dire de démontrer que les
crédits seraient bien à l'augmentation
et qu'il serait vraiment dépensé je
pense que désormais la démonstration a
été faite et donc il faut revenir un
avoir un accès qui soit précis sur les
choses qui comptent et ne pas à mon avis
aller quelque chose qui serait de par là
trop bavard et donc qui rendrait
d'ailleurs la lisibilité de la LPM pour
nos concitoyens qui la consulterait de
par trop difficile mais enfin là aussi
votre droit d'amendement viendra le cas
échéant corriger les choses voilà
monsieur le Président j'ai tenté d'être
le plus précis possible en renvoyant
évidemment certains sujets de
conversation à la présentation de la LPM
vous le comprendrez bien puisque sinon
je vais manquer de temps pour tout
traiter mais je peux évidemment revenir
sur les rapports sénatoriaux que j'ai lu
avec beaucoup d'attention dans les deux
cas et peut-être en refaire un
commentaire si vous le souhaitez et puis
et puis peut-être non il y a aussi des
il y a aussi des critiques sur le site
internet rassurez-vous
non mais en tout cas je m'en suis
beaucoup inspiré je pourrais évidemment
vous dire ce que nous en avons retenu et
ce qui nous semble judicieux justement
de reprendre ce qui nous semble moins
judicieux et puis peut-être que on peut
aussi partir du principe que sur
l'Ukraine on rentre peut-être
directement dans un jeu de
questions-réponses monsieur le président
ça permettra de d'être plus efficace et
de ne pas manger tout le temps
alors
si vous merci monsieur le ministre pour
cette pour cette présentation si vous le
voulez bien
si vous le oui tout à fait ça va très
bien
je vais donner la parole à nos
rapporteurs qui vont du reste m'aider
dans le travail de préparation de la LPM
en invitant chacun à la modération parce
que j'ai quand même un non seulement la
liste des rapports mais déjà un certain
nombre de collègues qui souhaitent
compléter votre propos et donc au titre
du 144 environnement et prospective de
la politique de défense
Pascal Alizard
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre d'abord merci pour la précision
et la clarté de vos propos je crois que
on est sur une bonne façon de travailler
ça mérite d'être
souligné ça c'est le premier point au
titre du programme 144 vous avez été
clair sur la partie renseignement et je
laisserai mon collègue Yannick
beaugrenard s'exprimer sur ce point moi
je voudrais connaître un petit peu votre
opinion sur la partie innovation
étudemment est-ce que vous avez déjà
alors je sais que l'innovation est
difficile après prévoir mais néanmoins
il faut prévoir les moyens de
l'innovation et et quels sont quels sont
les possibilités d'évolution des des
enveloppes ça c'est un point qui me
semble extrêmement important
deuxième point aussi
c'est la question du financement de
l'abbéité des et du financement de
l'économie de guerre alors effectivement
avec les événements du crâne par rapport
à ce qu'on pouvait constater il y a deux
ou trois ans la frilosité la compliance
de nos établissements bancaires les
choses évoluent un peu néanmoins pour
travailler régulièrement sur ce sujet
dans le cadre de la préparation de cette
LPM si on peut constater je parle pas
bien évidemment de votre ministère ou de
la DGA mais Bercy a fait un pas
important me semble-t-il c'est pas
encore complètement vrai de tous les
acteurs bancaires et tous les acteurs de
financement donc est-ce qu'il faut
prévoir des dispositions législatives
dans l'alpm à ce titre c'est une
question que que je pose
et le dernier point mais le président en
a parlé c'est effectivement la question
du la question du timing
est-ce que cela vous ai parlé de mai
juin c'est c'est une large enveloppe
on sait pas plus zoomer que ça pour le
moment voilà monsieur le Président je ne
suis pas plus long j'aurais plein
d'autres questions sinon merci
on fait on prend d'abord les rapporteurs
et puis après on fait les questions
minutes Yannick vogrenard toujours sur
le 144 merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre le déclenchement de
la guerre en Ukraine mais pas seulement
également notre engagement en Afrique a
montré l'importance d'avoir des moyens
souverains mais également efficace en
matière de renseignement afin d'une part
de préserver notre autonomie de décision
et surtout notre capacité d'anticipation
des menaces
vous avez rappelé les propos du
président de la République la loi de
programmation militaire à venir devrait
augmenter je cite massivement les
crédits de renseignement de près de 60%
et à l'intérieur un doublement du budget
de la Direction du renseignement
militaire et la Direction du
renseignement de la sécurité de la
défense des RSD
l'édifice sont en effet extrêmement
nombreux les lois de programmation
militaire
2019-2025 comportait un objectif de 1500
nouveaux emplois pour renforcer les
effectifs de la cyberdéfense vous l'avez
évoqué du renseignement allons-nous de
manière très significative amplifiée ces
recrutements et sous quel délai ce qui
s'opposera bien entendu de renforcer les
filières de formation et l'attractivité
des carrières et nous savons que ceci ne
se fait pas en un mois ou même un
trimestre la déchets la DGSE est dans
une moindre mesure la Direction du
renseignement et la sécurité de la
défense la drsd sont engagés dans
d'importants projets de modernisation de
leur siège de développement de leur
capacité cyber et d'accroissement de
leur activité opérationnelle globalement
pour ce que vous pourrez nous en dire
publiquement quels seront les principaux
axes d'effort de la prochaine LPM
sachant que anticiper avoir un coût
d'avance grâce au renseignement et
souvent extrêmement déterminant merci
merci Yannick on va passer au programme
146 équipement des forces avec un seul
rapporteur Cédric Perrin merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre ce
ministre merci pour vos propos
j'ai mis les industriels allemands ont
désormais acté la percée des industries
d'armement américaines avec la guerre en
Ukraine et il anticipe certains
industriels allemands de l'armement se
rapprochent actuellement d'industrie et
l'américains avec l'objectif de devenir
sous-traitant à une métal semble avoir
franchi le pas et Airbus s'interroger
sur cette question tous ces éléments
semblent malheureusement renforcés les
divergences d'intérêts franco-allemand
c'est bien dommage Franck own le dont je
rappelle je rappelle les dirigeant de
l'Alliance Nexter KMW aurait affirmé en
interne que le mgcs ne verrait pas le
jour avant 2045 2050 les Allemands
veulent désormais des Léopards de à 7 à
un Trophy il s'interroge sur un
rapprochement plus important avec les
États-Unis et s'interroge sur le protège
ces questions sont évidemment lourdes de
deux sens en termes de relations
politiques mais surtout d'avenir de nos
programmes de coopération industrielle
et particulièrement d'armement qu'en
est-il monsieur Miss de l'avenir du mgcs
si les USA complexent les dons de chars
l'Ukraine par des chars
même question évidemment sur l'avenir du
Skaff qui si les USA poussent le 35 en
remplacement d'hypothétique dont des
Européens à l'Ukraine de F16 ce ministre
qu'on aurait pu imaginer que la guerre
en Ukraine relance la coopération
franco-allemande sur ces sujets mais
malheureusement il ne semble pas que ce
soit la direction que l'on prenne est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
sur la manière dont vous voyez cette
coopération évoluée si vous pouvez
également nous dire quelle stratégie
vous comptez adopter est-ce qu'on ne
doit pas finalement envisager
sérieusement de produire rapidement les
blindés de BMT de de l'Alliance Nexter
quand même DS et j'ai une petite
question rapide puisqu'elle est n'est
pas là Monsieur le Ministre l'impact de
l'inflation serait de 30 milliards
d'euros sur les 400 + 13 milliards
d'euros de proposer en LPM mais les
hausses de prix propre au secteur de la
défense sont généralement supérieurs à
l'inflation est-ce qu'il ne faut pas
alors revoir cette évaluation à la
hausse une trajectoire en neuroconstante
serait-elle pas souhaitable pour
sécuriser l'investissement puisqu'on est
sur une période beaucoup plus importante
et dernière question on entend que le
programme du tigre 3 enfin tigre
standard 3 serait abandonné ça fait une
petite même un petit moment maintenant
qu'on entend cette petite musique au
profit d'un programme de modernisation
moins ambitieux qui traiterait quelques
obsolescences est-ce que vous confirmez
cette information et quels sont les
conséquences qu'elle serait en tout cas
les conséquences de cette décision
notamment pour le développement d'une
solution française dessus en
substitution du Hellfire qui équipe
actuellement les tigres je rappelle que
les Allemands nous ont abandonné sur
cette question il y a quelques mois et
qu'on a eu beaucoup de mal à convaincre
les Espagnols qui risquent à leur tour
d'être abandonnés par les français si
toutefois on devait nous aussi
abandonner le programme standard 3 du
tigre merci monsieur le ministre
merci Cédric on va passer au 178
préparation emplois des forces Olivier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le programme 178 et le cœur de
la mission défense portant sur la
préparation et l'emploi des hommes et
vous comprendrez que que nos questions
et nous inquiétudes sont assez précises
sur un certain nombre de points que je
me propose de détailler tout d'abord
concernant l'entretien programmé du
matériel est-ce que l'enveloppe des
crédits alloués sera dimensionnée à la
bonne hauteur pour la prochaine période
de programmation vous avez évoqué la fin
de la période
OPEX pour l'opération barkhane mais nous
savons qu'il y a un certain nombre de
matériels qui vont faire l'objet d'une
métropolisation d'où la nécessité
d'augmenter les crédits pour remettre à
niveau ces matériels et leur
réaffectation dans les différentes
composantes
deuxième inquiétude pour les rapporteurs
du 518 la reconstitution des stocks de
munitions vous l'avez évoqué également
avec l'aspect souveraineté mais est-ce
que cette reconstitution des stocks de
munitions sera réalisée non pas à la
hauteur des contrats opérationnels
dégradés mais bien à la hauteur d'une
hypothèse d'engagement majeur vous
l'avez évoqué à produire reprise et ça
fait partie de nos interrogations
concernant les les Opex vous avez
précisé à juste titre que le budget OPEX
sera diminué puisque l'opération
barkhane a été les provisions pardon
l'opération barkhane a été clôturée lors
d'une annonce par le Président de la
République le 9 novembre mais qu'en
est-il des engagements des coulant de
l'OTAN et notamment les missions de
l'assurance est-ce qu'un dispositif sera
prévu de nature à protéger l'enveloppe
de LPM pour la prochaine période
budgétaire
enfin concernant la préparation
opérationnelle est-ce que vous envisagez
un affichage annuel
au-delà des standards au temps est-ce
que nous disposerons chaque année des
objectifs de rattrapage concernant ces
normes au temps et puis dernière
interrogation mais vous nous avez
partiellement répondu déjà dans le cadre
de votre propolyminaire concernant les
services de soutien dont nous souhaitons
saluer l'excellence c'est bien sûr le
service de santé des armées les services
du commissariat des armées les services
interarmés des munitions et les services
de l'énergie opérationnelle vous nous
avez apporté déjà quelques quelques
réponses sur ce point et puis dernier
sujet vous avez
apporté devant notre commission un
élément important concernant l'aide à
l'Ukraine qui sera sortie de la LPM
est-ce que cela vaut pour le matériel
seulement qui est cédé à l'Ukraine ou
est-ce que ça porte également sur
l'entretien programmé du matériel
nécessaire pour maintenir de façon
opérationnelle les matériels dont nous
continuons à utiliser voilà merci
Monsieur le Ministre merci on enchaîne
sur le 178 avec Michel et Grau
c'est toi qui fait les deux ah d'accord
je croyais que tu passais la parole bon
très bien alors nous passons au 212
soutien de la politique de défense Joël
guerriot
oui monsieur le ministre lors de ses
vœux le président de la République avait
annoncé que le service national
universel sera amené à évoluer vous
savez que moi que ça dispositif hybride
qui a qui a conduit à peu près quelques
quelques militaires à assumer demi
journée de formation dans le courant de
l'année précédente or si demain on
devait généraliser à toute une classe
d'âge c'est à dire à 800.000 jeunes qui
seraient accueillis chaque année dans le
cadre de du SNU évidemment les
conséquences seront différentes nous
avions en ce qui nous concerne introduit
un amendement pour que on puisse
empêcher que le déploiement du SNU ne
vienne empiéter sur la consolidation de
nos armées quand sera-t-il demain et
donc ma question est la politique de
service national universel qui est
aujourd'hui essentiellement civile
entraînera-t-elle dans le champ de la
prochaine loi sera peut-être plus en
considération dans le champ de la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
est-ce qu'il y aura des conséquences en
termes de besoins d'encadrement de la
part de nos militaires et avez-vous
prévu des garde-fous pour que la
trajectoire de redressement financier
des armées ne soit pas menacé par le
financement de cette politique qui
évidemment serait d'une forte envergure
avec 800 000 jeunes
par ailleurs plus de 4 ans après
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi de
programmation militaire actuelle que
vous avez qualifié de loi de réparation
le nombre des effectifs au ministère des
armées s’élève à 273000 personnes
environ ces effectifs correspondent bien
à redressement puisque c'est 4000 postes
qui ont été créés dans le périmètre du
ministère depuis 2019 toutefois il faut
souligner que redressement est relatif
puisqu'il intervient après plusieurs
décennies de déflation brutale depuis la
professionnalisation des armées
décidaient en 1996 et cette période de
déflation a été accentuée dans les
années 2000 par la révision générale des
politiques publiques en dépit de la
version de la trajectoire depuis 2015 le
ministère désormais emploie aujourd'hui
5000 personnes de moins qu'il y a 10 ans
ce qui m'amène la question suivante
est-ce que la loi de programmation
militaire de transformation que vous
avez annoncé prévoira d'augmenter des
effectifs de nos forces armées et le cas
échéant quel serait les secteurs
prioritaires dans lesquels le ministère
doit selon vous étouffer ses ressources
humaines merci de votre attention merci
on va stopper la les interrogations pour
vous laisser la possibilité de répondre
au rapporteur et après je prendrai la
suite des questions merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président peut-être que je
commence par votre question sur
l'Afrique
bien déjà je pense qu'il faut qu'on
arrive objectiver et redire devant cette
commission ce que font les bases
militaires françaises actuellement en
Afrique parce qu'elles n'ont pas toutes
les mêmes missions et je suis frappé de
voir dans les commentaires du jour
quelques approximations quelques grands
mélanges qui sont un peu désespérants
parfois puisque les missions certaines
nobazes quand même datent des années 60
alors qu'en 2023 certains commentateurs
de la vie publique n'est pas encore
compris à quoi sert la base de
Port-Bouët Abidjan et me rend un peu
triste pour être honnête avec vous bon
il se trouve que la France a des je
parle pas évidemment des forces
spéciales sur lesquelles comme vous le
savez n'est pas d'usage que le ministre
sont aussi une audition captée
évidemment s'exprime en tout cas pour
ceux qui relèvent des forces dites
prépositionnées c'est-à-dire dans lequel
un État souverain a décidé par un accord
de défense souvent lors de l'accession à
l'indépendance dans notre histoire
commune avec ces différents pays ou
après ont décidé de d'accepter des
forces avec un pas bon c'est vraiment en
Côte d'Ivoire c'est vrai au Tchad c'est
vrai Djibouti et de manière plus récente
je parle pas de mission nusienne je
parle pas des missions européennes je
parle véritablement des forces
prépositionnées je suis précis dans mes
dans mes mots et c'est vrai évidemment
de manière plus récente avec avec le
Niger sur lequel comme vous le savez une
partie du déménagement des
infrastructures de barkhane du Mali ce
sont faites vers le Niger et sur lequel
sous le contrôle de l'armée des
autorités du Niger nous menons un
certain nombre de parfois d'opérations
mais qui se font systématiquement à la
demande du partenaire nigérien la
réflexion que le Président de la
République m'a demandé de conduire
concerne assez spécifiquement le Tchad
la Côte d'Ivoire le Sénégal et le Gabon
Djibouti étant d'une base avec un accord
de défense et des clauses de sécurité
qui concernent la France et Djibouti
mais qui comme vous le savez est aussi
très tourné vers l'Indopacifique donc du
boudding ne fait pas partie du spectre
de la réflexion je le précise tout de
suite
ensuite parmi ces bases elles n'ont pas
toutes le même rôle disais-je le Gabon
ou le Sénégal pour ne citer que ces
deux-là sont des bases dans lesquelles
vous n'avez aucun équipement
d'intervention en particulier
c'est-à-dire en clair ce sont des forces
prépositionnées qui ne font que de la
formation uniquement de la formation je
crois que
Dakar si vous avez quatre ou cinq V AB
pour seul de tout compte en armement en
équipements pardonnez-moi évidemment
vous avez l'armement individuel de nos
soldats pour ce pour se protéger et vous
avez des bases dans lequel vous avez des
fonctions de formation mais vous avez
également des fonctions d'intervention
et je pense particulièrement à Abidjan
Port-Bouët dans lequel vous avez
effectivement à la fois une offre de
formation mais aussi des capacités à
intervenir je le précise pareil pour le
chat je précise parce que si on mélange
des fonctions de toutes les bases on
peut pas comprendre pourquoi certaines
sont à une classe 1000 et pourquoi
d'autres sont un des classes 450 500 je
précise que les chiffres parfois n'ont
pas
[Musique]
petit jeu je lui disais depuis
maintenant de nombreuses années le sujet
désormais étant de coller et de
correspondre aux attentes des
partenaires en question et en font même
si ça fait de nombreuses décennies qu'on
fait parfois toujours la même chose
présente la République a estimé au gré
des rencontres des discussions je pense
que c'est pareil pour nos chefs
d'état-major au gré des rencontres et
des discussions avec les chefs
d'état-major des armées africaines
concernées qu'il était temps de mettre à
jour notre présence et donc s'ensuit
désormais un dialogue qui d'ailleurs
n'est pas le même en fonction des états
et en fonction des pays puisque leur
degré d'attente ou d'avancement dans la
réflexion n'est pas complètement même
donc on va vers des bases qui seraient
plus ouvertes donc je le dis aussi tout
de suite aucune fermeture contrairement
à ce qui se dit ici ou là sans mauvais
jeu de mots c'est non seulement il y a
pas de fermeture on serait même plutôt
sur une ouverture aux partenaires
africains du pays qui nous accueille
dans notre capacité à former plus soit
formé plus en nombre de Zelda des armées
africaines concernées formées en unités
constituée officiers sous-officier
tamajor homme Durand soit formé
davantage en qualité de formation je
pense que notre capacité à former sur
les forces spéciales par exemple sont un
point absolument majeur dans notre notre
capacité à donner quelque chose de
qualité évidemment sur le sur le terrain
capacité aussi parfois à répondre à des
besoins nouveaux un exemple sans travers
les secrets des discussions que nous
éventuellement avec le partenaires la
Côte d'Ivoire a une armée d'emploi
disais-je qui malheureusement fait face
au terrorisme et donc de plus en plus
ils ont besoin de centres de
reconditionnement pour leur soldats un
peu comme nos maisons Atos comme le
service de santé des armées peuvent
faire et là ils ont besoin d'un
accompagnement nous donc on est en train
de faire un sur-mesure qui pourrait
évidemment se traduire par des
diminutions de nombre de soldats
français dans les emprises et pour cause
puisque l'idée étant d'avoir des soldats
des armées des pays qui nous accueillent
en partenariat dans ses emprises bon
donc ça j'ai pas de Quantum à donner
aujourd'hui parce que le travail va
prendre encore du temps dans les
semaines dans les mois qui viennent moi
je pense que c'est une opportunité
historique pour l'armée française parce
qu'on accompagne une montée en puissance
d'État qui sont des amis qui eux pour le
coup ont décidé de lutter contre le
terrorisme comprendrait ce que je veux
dire par là par rapport à d'autres et
donc c'est pas du tout un recul de la
France dans ces pays au contraire c'est
une manière d'être présent différemment
en plus grande intimité et en plus grand
partenariat enfin je rappelle parce que
je suis quand même un peu heurté de
certains commentaires pour être
complètement transparent avec vous que
ce sont des États souverains et que
notre présence correspond aussi à ce
qu'ils veulent et que certains temps
sont terminés et que donc quand je vois
aussi un ravant de commentateurs nous
expliquer que faut mettre plus de monde
où il aurait fallu pas fallu partir du
Burkina Faso je trouve que c'est tout à
fait stupéfiant de venir caricaturer
remettre en cause la souveraineté même
si parfois ce sont des pouvoirs qui ne
sont pas légitimes issus de coup d'état
et qui sont des jantes on ne peut pas
fouder aux pieds la souveraineté des
pays en question voilà j'aurai
l'occasion de revenir devant la
commission sur l'état d'avancement de
ces discussions en tout cas il y a une
occasion historique d'avoir une présence
militaire toujours aussi affirmée mais
qui prend un visage un peu différent qui
donne aussi droit à plus de choses de
grande qualité et qui nécessairement
aussi on reverra dans la LPM traduit des
capacités de projection de l'armée
française par un échelon national
d'urgence qui va être évidemment
renforcé des capacités à se projeter
depuis l'hexagone dans ces différents
pays puisque là aussi dire que ce sont
les forces armées françaises au Gabon au
Sénégal qui sont qui ont des capacités
importantes à intervenir c'est mentir
puisque n'était pas le cas aujourd'hui
pour avancer oui monsieur
alors pour le coup les discussions
par le ministre des skinny m'interroge
sur le la base aérienne et sur les
forces prépositionnées au Tchad le
ministre a raison de m'interpeller c'est
le territoire le pays sur lequel je n'ai
pas encore démarré les discussions ma
priorité était Côte d'Ivoire et
port-bouée l'état de maturité est
important de discussion avec mon
homologue et le président Ouattara avec
les forces armées ivoiriennes vous avez
raison de parler du chat parce que il
est cerné par des pays dans la situation
sécuritaire et pour le moins préoccupant
et donc au fond le Tchad est un peu dans
la même situation que la Côte d'Ivoire
puisque nous avons des forces
importantes vous le savez mieux
quiconque avec des capacités
d'intervention et j'ai envie de dire
Sénégal Gabon font partie d'une autre
famille puisque là pour le coup il y a
pas ses capacités d'interventions mais
de fait vous avez raison de
m'interpeller sur le chat mais ça fait
partie des pays sur lequel je dois
avancer désormais dans ma dans ma copie
voilà
pour les autres
interpellations remarque et questions
monsieur le sénateur alizar sur
l'innovation bon déjà pour l'innovation
en propre de la DGA dans la LPM actuelle
il y avait un milliard d'euros qui était
qui était prévu dans la LPM que je vous
présenterai on va multiplier par 10 et
porter à 10 milliards d'euros l'effort
et ça c'est l'effort propre déjà parce
que l'innovation vous en retrouvez tous
les étages du ministère des armées des
GSE dans les Forces Spéciales y compris
dans les forces conventionnelles y
compris dans la dissuasion nucléaire
vous avez de l'innovation partout mais
je vous réponds très précisément sur le
programme dont vous avez la
responsabilité on multiplie par 10
deuxième des choses moi je veux demander
à ce que la BTD prenne davantage aussi
de risques sur sa part propre de
financement d'innovation
c'est pas que glorieux mais je le
rappelle les canons César dans leur
histoire sont un des exemples
d'innovation porté par l'industriel en
question contre la vie non pas du
ministre de l'époque et d'ailleurs
sénateur c'est un Richard mais du
ministère de l'époque mais c'est un la
Richard qui donne droit à comment dire à
l'industriel le fait d'avancer sur cet
élément d'innovation je pense aussi
qu'il faut désormais qu'on y mélange
l'argent public et l'argent privé dans
cette affaire la dualité
bien connue de ce ministère mais sur
lequel évidemment il faut qu'on puisse
avancer sur le financement de la BTD moi
j'y crois beaucoup c'est un sujet clé et
ce qu'il faut des mesures législatives
dédiées je ne sais pas répondre à cette
question en tout cas ce que je sais ce
que je vois c'est un il y a un combat
communautaire européen a mené taxonomie
prononcer le mot c'est clair c'est clair
il faut qu'on fasse bloc tous ensemble
évidemment sur ce sujet de moi je l'ai
dit publiquement et je le redis ici je
fais aussi quand même une forme de
finance patriotique c'est-à-dire quand
je vois le nombre de PME de labilité qui
se font rejeter leur demande de
financement bancaire uniquement parce
que c'est de l'armement alors que
parfois ce sont des enfin c'est pas
parfois c'est l'argent des Français par
ailleurs par les pagne et qui peut être
sollicité là je pense que dans cette
commission est collectivement on a
quelque chose à faire monter dans le
débat public est-ce que c'est une mesure
réglementaire ou législative pas
forcément en tout cas il faut aussi
qu'on soit capable de sensibiliser la la
place bancaire sur cette affaire et on a
trop de refus et trop de demandes qui
nous reviennent moi j'ai donné aussi
mandat à la DGA sur cette affaire je
précise que certaines initiatives par
ailleurs de fonds d'investissement sont
en train de naître et que parfois
certaines grandes entreprises de la BITD
ne viennent pas le financer non plus
non mais la parole est libre je suis le
président donc je le dis voilà donc je
c’était il y avait un grand papier dans
la presse il y a pas très longtemps sur
une initiative d'un fond
d'investissement ça me semble
intéressant je suis frappé de voir que
les grandes entreprises de notre pays TD
ne répondent pas tout de suite présent à
cette affaire donc là je pense que le
sujet de l'investissement
ouais mais je pense aussi que c'est bien
d'aller chercher enfin là où il y a de
l'innovation de l'investissement il y a
forcément un rapport à de la dette je
veux dire c'est
les entrepreneurs on comprend ça et on
est bien d'accord donc ça je pense que
c'est un sujet qui est absolument clé
calendrier en fait moi je suis votre
serviteur donc par définition je serai
au bon moment de demandera de lettres je
crois que c'est la discussion globale en
conférence de président moi j'avais une
LPM potentiellement à l'Assemblée
nationale au mois de mai potentiellement
en juin au Sénat le Président c'est
peut-être plus que moi en tout cas une
fois plus moi je me tiens prêt voilà je
déduis simplement que généralement la
ratification des LPM et la publication a
lieu avant le 14 juillet donc on peut
imaginer alors généralement pas beaucoup
de temps pour la généralement de manière
récente pour la force du symbole après
j'ai regardé là aussi dans l'histoire on
a même eu des LPM qui se sont conclus
alors que les discussions de la loi de
finances avaient déjà démarré enfin on
retrouve de tout depuis les années 60 en
tout cas moi je me tiens prêt à tenir
les les délais une fois de plus c'est au
gouvernement d'être à disposition du
Parlement pour cette affaire donc voilà
sur le renseignement merci d'avoir
recité les chiffres de 60%
d'augmentation dont la multiplication
par 2 pour la DSD la DRM ce qui est
évidemment historique vous l'avez tout
de suite dit le l'enjeu il est pas temps
budgétaire il va être RH désormais non
pas tant pour recruter mais pour
fidéliser et c'est particulièrement vrai
pour la DGSE que vous connaissez bien et
c'est encore plus vrai pour les métiers
du cyber dans lequel on a une jeune
génération qui évidemment est heureuse
de pouvoir faire ses premières armes et
les premières lignes de son CV au sein
de la boîte
lors des premières années de leur
carrière et pour évidemment des enjeux
qui sont financiers mais pas que
d'ailleurs
les l'ensemble des instruments du
salaire enfin l'ensemble de la galaxie
de la fidélisation sont amenés à être
chassés par des entreprises du du privé
avec des solutions ou en tout cas des
offres matériels en tout cas beaucoup
plus importantes donc là il est clair
que j'aurai des propositions si vous
faire sachant que
il y aura pas non plus de miracle c'est
un travail de longue haleine et vous
l'avez dit vous-même ça ne se fera pas
une seule fois la copie comprend
évidemment de renseignements je vais
parler des drones forcément des éléments
liés au drone pour les services de
renseignement et le cyber évidemment une
partie des grands investissements cybers
sont aussi pour pour nos services de
renseignement mais là peut-être aussi
que j'aurai l'occasion de vendre la DPR
peut-être de présenter des copies plus
précises puisque notre audition est en
captée évidemment un certain nombre
d'éléments sont couverts par le par le
secret mais ce n'est pas pour autant que
je me tiens pas la disposition du Sénat
dans dans le format qu'il vous
conviendra monsieur le sénateur Perrin
alors sur l'Allemagne
et l'industrie allemande et l'attirance
pour pour Washington bon au-delà de mes
notes moi je j'aime la littérature je
relisais il y a pas très longtemps
l'excellence était de Gaulle de
Peyrefitte dans lequel justement perfide
interrol le général de Gaulle à la fin
d'un conseiller des ministres sur les
propos qu'il a tenu sur l'OTAN sur
l'Union européenne et l'OTAN sur la
relation entre l'Allemagne et Washington
on est en 1962 donc en fait on voit que
tout cela n'est pas très nouveau et
qu'en fait je pense que sur le
franco-allemand il faut faire preuve de
patience puisque visiblement il n'y a
pas une ligne que je retirerai de
l'échange que le général de Gaulle a
avec a avec son ministre de
l'Information et porte-parole du
gouvernement de l'époque et au fond on
le voit bien il y a une déjà faut poser
un diagnostic sur ce qui se passe en
Allemagne
ce que veut le chancelier et les
ministres ne correspond pas toujours à
ce que veut les industriels
c'est pas propre à l'Allemagne des
choses que je souhaite que pour
lesquelles nos industriels résistent le
dit manière bienveillante donc je vois
bien que parfois il y a des stratégies
qui peuvent être divergentes et deuxième
des choses peut-être plus propre à
l'Allemagne parfois les industriels ne
sont franchement pas d'accord entre eux
ce qui est encore plus marqué que chez
nous pour le coup et sur le mgcs vous
avez cité une entreprise qui aura une
métal vous en avez cité une autre qui
est knds on voit bien que parfois on
peut nous-même être spectateur de
désaccord non pas interne à l'appareil
politique c'est pas nouveau mais enfin
il faut le il faut le traiter comme
comme tel donc moi il y a des choses
aussi qui sont pas nouvelles enfin une
métal est déjà sous-traitant d'un
certain nombre d'industries à
l'américains ça ne date pas d'hier si je
renvoie à l'histoire moi je vous ai déjà
fait cette réponse et je vous la refais
pour le enfin je vous ai déjà fait cette
réponse pour le Scaff et je vous le
refais bien volontiers pour le mgcs
c'est je pense qu'on a besoin de ces
coopérations y compris pour à moisir la
facture pour le contribble français
que deux jours je vous renvoie aussi à
peine c'était de Gaulle déjà à l'époque
les mêmes idées de coopération étaient
sur la table sur certains segments ça a
fonctionné pour certains ça n'a pas
fonctionné pour d'autres et que 3 rien
est grave dès lors qu'on est capable de
défendre nos intérêts et notre capacité
à véritablement délivrer le programme
d'armement dont nous avons besoin c'est
vrai pour le mgcs je vais m'envie de
dire c'est encore plus vrai pour le MGCF
que pour le Scaff puisque nous aurons
besoin d'un char avant calendairement un
avion du futur donc là aussi j'aurai
l'occasion de revenir devant vous sur
sur ces sujets mais il est clair que la
rénovation du Charles Leclerc ne pourra
pas nous emmener dans de nombreuses
décennies et qu'il nous faudra bien
avoir une solution sur ce segment là en
d'ailleurs une introduisant d'autres
sujets qui vous sont favoris la question
des drones la question aussi des sauts
technologiques sur cette affaire là
puisqu'on le voit bien rusticité masse
versus sa technologie là il y a des
points d'équilibre à trouver sur lequel
évidemment il faudra prendre des
décisions pas tant d'ailleurs dans cette
LPM là intégralement
un peu mais surtout dans la prochaine là
pour le coup il y aura des grands des
grands coups près qui vont qui vont
tomber puis enfin je l'ai déjà dit aussi
devant le Sénat je pense qu'il faut
continuer de diversifier nos
partenariats
et c'est pour ça que moi je passe
beaucoup de temps avec les Italiens et
les Britanniques pour par exemple MBDA
c'est pour cela que je pense qu'il ne
faut s'interdire aucune collaboration
dans des formats voilà je note que pour
le Scaff certains pays européens qui
avaient regardé peut-être ailleurs sur
une autre coopération voisine peut se
rapprocher de nous les choses bougent je
pense que c'est à nous d'avoir une
posture très ouverte considérant que
quoi qu'il arrive il nous faudra un
avion et il nous faudra un char une fois
que je l'ai dit après nous de d'être en
capacité justement d'être assemblée de
ces de ces différentes alliances ou
partenariats sur l'inflation bon moi
j'ai pris les
projections de Bercy bien élevées que je
suis pour bâtir évidemment la la les
perspectives pour pour cette LPM
globalement le chiffre de 30 milliards
et
est assez conforme bon moi je constate
quand même qu'on s'intéresse à
l'inflation lorsqu'elle est hausse haute
personne ne s'y intéresser lorsqu'elle
était basse dire que les critères
macroéconomiques de 2017-2018 2019 font
que les projections étaient plutôt n’est
pas compte de l'inflation et que
derrière un certain nombre de choses on
gonflé dans la copie que désormais il
s'agit de traiter cette copie dont
l'inflation évidemment la fait gonfler
là c'est quand même une autre affaire
c'est qu'on a pris des critères qui sont
très dégradés et très pessimistes sur
lequel j'ai aussi bon espoir c'est pas
un pari que je fais mais en tout cas je
le dis par honnêteté intellectuelle on
aura géespère quand même des
renversements de tendance sur
l'inflation dans les cinq ans qui
viennent et même si on en avait pas on a
pris les projections les plus
désagréables pour bâtir la copie voilà
ça aussi je documenterai je le montrerai
dans la discussion parlementaire et
après évidemment de toute façon cette
inflation
ça ne s'applique pas au seul ministère
des armées sur le standard 3 alors
beaucoup de choses circulent
oui mais en fait le plus réel n'empêche
pas la nullité budgétaire là aussi j'en
ai fait la démonstration avec en gestion
exactement et d'ailleurs malheureusement
le passé la démontré les LPM était
joyeux et généreuses et les crédits
budgétaires n'étaient pas là
annuellement bon donc en fait je renvoie
aussi certes à la programmation on prend
des critères pour faire cette
programmation jadis d'ailleurs il y
avait pas autant de choses dans la
programmation il y avait pas les Opex il
y avait absolument pas la maintenance du
matériel il y avait pas l'entretien des
forces il y avait pas l'activité il y
avait que l'investissement est très
nucléaire d'ailleurs pour les premiers
LPM donc tout ça vous coupez évoluer
donc en fait c'est la dualité budgétaire
qui va nous permettre aussi de traiter
cette affaire à la hausse comme à la
baisse la recommandation que je me fais
à moi-même c'est que si on devait avoir
des critères qui s'améliorent c'est de
ne procéder à aucun bourrage ciao aucun
aucune dépense non décidé valablement
sans ressources nouvelles ce qui
permettra de garder de la flexibilité
pendant la conduite de la LPM tigre bon
déjà beaucoup de choses circulent qui
sont parfois inexactes
l'hélicoptère tique continuera à voler
jusqu'en 2040 2045 je le dis parce que
oui mais vous vous l'êtes mais la rumeur
parfois beaucoup moins donc je le dis
après le vrai sujet c'est le saut
technologique et donc moi j'ai demandé
je suis pas le seul à le demander
d'autres pays européens le font aux
armées de regarder si ce qui est imaginé
pour le standard 3 correspond bien à ce
qu'on veut alors ce qu'on veut
technologiquement
question des drones que vous connaissez
mieux quiconque etc est-ce que est-ce
qu'on aura pas un super hélicoptère déjà
démodé ma question elle est pas médiocre
me semble-t-il donc j'assume de la poser
publiquement et la deuxième des choses
c'est la soutenabilité économique du
tigre 3 c'est à dire que si le cocktail
est génial mais qu'on peut acheter
seulement quelques-uns qu'on aura des
difficultés à l'exporter c'est une
difficulté donc là je réinterroge non
pas le principe du standard 3 j'aurais
interroge le modèle qu'il existe
aujourd'hui et j'ai donné mandat aux
armées à la DGA en lien avec les
industriels le cas échange de le mettre
à jour ou de le faire évoluer si le
besoin en est tout simplement parce que
2040 personne ne comprendrait que je
fiche complètement la copie et que qui
n'en soit pas autrement vous voyez c'est
ce n'est pas une mauvaise nouvelle c'est
juste une bonne nouvelle qu'il faut
adapter monsieur le Center sigoletti sur
les soutiens merci d'être revenu c'est
absolument clé le sénateur je le gario
d'ailleurs il était revenu lui-même par
un amendement sur le SCAR pendant la
discussion budgétaire et je le remercie
et il faut continuer à faire nos efforts
parce que personne ne comprendrait que
la réparation s'arrête maintenant bon
donc là aussi évidemment je reviendrai
pareil sur l'entretien du matériel
peut-être donner un chiffre que je n'ai
jamais là aussi donné publiquement vous
êtes enfin non pas inquiet mais vous
formez le vœu que tout ça continue
d'avancer sur l'entretien programmé du
matériel la LPM actuelle était à 35
milliards d'euros la proposition que je
vais vous faire est à 49 milliards
d'euros donc on est sur une rotation de
40% c'est absolument spectaculaire je le
dis aussi néanmoins il faut que ça se
traduise par des effets réels et non pas
par une augmentation des coûts du MCO et
donc ça aussi ça fait partie du dialogue
avec la BITD parce que si on paye
plusieurs fois le matériel en question
en entretien ce n'est pas de bonne
gestion donc là évidemment aussi un
dialogue est en cours sur les Opex pas
d'inquiétude
on est en train de recalibrer tout ça la
réalité monsieur le sénateur c'est nul
ne sait aussi ce que notre renfort sur
le flanc oriental le l'OTAN donnera dans
les mois années qui viennent je ne parle
d'incertitude que je suis aussi de
devant vous pareil pour l'émission
intérieures il y a je vous le dis aussi
tout de suite une petite provision dans
la copie pour les Jeux Olympiques c'est
prévu comme ça au moins c'est dans la
copie en gestion on n'aura pas besoin de
vous le redemander mais en tout cas ça
c'est évidemment intégré les munitions
sujets cher au sénateurs Perrin après
est inquiet sur Twitter donc je comme il
est inquiet sur Twitter je veux tout de
suite le rassurer
qui aime bien châtie bien bon beaucoup
de commandes sont déjà réalisées je leur
ai dit ici dans cette audition captée
que ça soit sur les munitions de 155 mm
5000 ont été commandés en juillet 2022
c'est une nouvelle commande je précise
sur les mêmes P200 unités en décembre
2022 c'est une commande anticipée sans
Mistral en décembre 2022 on commande
anticiper plus de 200 missiles à stères
en décembre 2022 qui est une commande
anticipée qu'on fait en commun avec nos
amis italiens voilà un bon exemple de
Tonton parle jamais assez mais enfin on
fait des choses intéressantes avec avec
l'Italie avenir je peux vous annoncer
monsieur le Center sigleetti
16155 mm 16000 unités par la mémoire de
155 mm pour le mois de mars à venir de
cette année c'est une nouvelle commande
et ensuite trois commandes globales pour
mars 23 en lettres de commande pour là
aussi un volume manuel de 155 de 15000
munitions obus en 155 mm en MMP et en
Mistral voilà ça donne aussi tout de
suite le fait qu'on n'attend pas la
prochaine LPM pour le faire et quand on
dit qu'on le fait un retour d'expérience
de l'Ukraine on le fait vraiment on a
aucune raison évidemment de travestir la
réalité on va continuer évidemment de le
faire je présenterai évidemment la copie
munition de la LPN le moment venu sur
c'est essentiellement les sessions de
matériel puisque le MCO de ce qui est
donné est pris sur le fond de soutien
exceptionnel à l'Ukraine de 200 millions
d'euros que vous aviez voté monsieur le
sénateur guerriot
sur le SNU alors et c'est nu d'une part
et RH politique RH du ministère d'autre
part sur le senu bon déjà tous les
arbitrages sont pas rendus par le
Président de la République sur sur le
service national universel je rappelle
aussi que ce n'est pas un service
militaire quoi qu'il arrive parce que là
aussi beaucoup de contre-vérité ou
d'instrumentalisation notamment par la
France insoumise se font jour et donc je
veux le dire et que donc par définition
il n'y a pas de il y a pas de raison que
ce qui ne soit pas un service militaire
soit pris dans la LPM avec néanmoins une
précision moi j'ai mis quand même dans
la copie des provisions pour ce qui va
se brancher potentiellement sur le
ministère des armées dans les décisions
qui seront peut-être prises des
réflexions sont en cours pour des phases
de vol et qui pourrait servir de
passerelle avec nos réserves à ça
évidemment on commence à rentrer dans le
format des armées c'est donc à la LPM de
le prendre et on a j'ai détourré
précisément les choses en la matière
mais en tout cas je pourrai en faire la
démonstration je ne sais pas
complètement répondre à votre question
dès lors que je ne sais pas encore à
quoi complètement ressemblera ce nu mais
bon la secrétaire d'État continue d'y
travailler il est clair monsieur le
Président que
entre temps il faudra ainsi que la
Scotta revienne devant vous pour vous
présenter aussi ce à quoi sert le s&u
comment il va prendre forme et
évidemment comment le ministère des
armées apporte quelque chose mais c'est
pas le seul ministère qui va apporter
quelque chose dans cette affaire RH le
tableau RH tel que vous le connaissez la
LPM actuel sera reconduit puisque pour
le coup les objectifs n'ont pas été
remplis faut le reconnaître pratiquement
4500 à 5000 et TP donc pas été comblé
pas parce qu'on n'arrive pas à embaucher
parce qu'on n'arrive pas à fidéliser on
a une attrition et un flux c'est ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure pour pour les
services de renseignement et donc là on
va reprendre évidemment
les différents objectifs non le vrai
pivot RH c'est évidemment la réserve
qui s'ennuie le doute va changer le
format des armées puisque c'est pas tant
un chiffre de 100000 ça la Régence en
moquent c'est le ratio qui est
intéressant on arrive donc à 100000 mais
c'est de dire que pour deux militaires
d'actives on a un militaire de réserve
et ça pour le coup ça a un impact assez
historique sur le format des armées qui
est aussi historique que pas pour les
mêmes raisons les années 60 pas pour les
mêmes raisons les années 90 la fin du
service mais là on va évidemment vers
une modification du format des armées
qui n'est pas neutre et pour le coup
c'est dans la copie budgétaire tel que
je vous la présenterai parce qu'avoir
des réservices encore faut-il les
convoquer c'est à dire parfois un des
problèmes sur la fidélisation des
réservices que parfois il se sentent
inutiles ils sont pas assez convoqués il
faut les équiper il faut les entraîner
parce qu'avoir des réservistes que l'on
délaisse en matière d'entraînement ça
n'aurait pas de sens et ça pour le coup
c'est dans la copie des 413 milliards
d'euros voilà pardonnez-moi je suis
bavard mais j'essaie de le plus précis
possible merci monsieur le ministre pour
ces réponses au rapporteur on va prendre
des questions minutes minute
Jacques le nez
le président monsieur le ministre vous
nous avez exposé la situation en Afrique
et dans un article du 20 février un tour
récent le monde titré les États-Unis
engagent une stratégie pour évincer les
mercenaires de groupe Wagner d'Afrique
la France est-elle considérée comme un
partenaire dans cette démarche et dans
votre interview au Parisien du 18
février vous évoquiez l'équilibre à
trouver entre d'une part la rusticité et
la masse et d'autre part le niveau de
sophistication
technologique alors comment justement
trouver cet équilibre quels sont les
remontées du terrain à ce sujet
merci andriol
oui pour une grosse minute merci
président monsieur le ministre
actuellement un exercice intérieur mais
majeur se déroule dans le sud de notre
pays il s'agit de la séquence numéro une
l'exercice Orion 2023 une ampleur
inédite depuis trois décennies ces
grandes manœuvres mettent en action 7000
militaires français et étrangers cet
exercice multinational contribue à
préparer nos forces mais aussi nos
alliés à un combat de haute intensité
dont l'actualité vient de nous rappeler
la constante probabilité sachant que
depuis le 24 février 2022 l'Europe a su
parler d'une seule voie et que l'OTAN a
retrouvé sa légitimité sécuritaire
comment cet exercice peut mettre en
évidence à la lumière de ces événements
la nécessité de disposer en Europe d'un
pilier de défense autant
un pilier qui sera d'autant plus fort
qui reposera aussi sont un dispositif
militarro-industriel européen et ça
vient d'être évoqué à ce sujet j'ai bien
noté la réponse de l'ambassadeur
d'Allemagne en France lors de son
audition à qui nous demandions les
raisons d'acquisition faites par son
pays le matériel américain une réponse
rassurante à défaut d'être complètement
satisfaisante pour la France qui
expliquait que l'Allemagne avait besoin
de s'équiper rapidement et qui convenait
d'acheter du matériel sur étagère pour
reprendre l'expression de Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur mais qu'à terme c'est
leurs acquisitions se feraient en
partenariat avec les européens tels que
le SCAF et le charme futur de combat
mais j'entends aussi les inquiétudes
formulées par notre collègue Cédric
Perrin car il faut bien rappeler sans
paraphraser le discours de François
Mitterrand prononcer au moment du
déploiement des SS20 que si que si les
centres de gravité militaires et
industrielle de l'OTAN se situe bien en
Amérique force de constater que les
conflits sont bien trop souvent en
Europe aussi ma question monsieur le
ministre comment s'inscrit l'OTAN dans
l'organisation de cet exercice au
royaume 2023 et quelle est l'implication
de l'Allemagne son dispositif qu'il
conviendrait de réorienter si cela n'est
pas en cours sachant que cette opération
des vergure a été décidé en 2021 par
conséquent avant l'invasion de l'Ukraine
par la Russie et qu'à un moment où
l'OTAN était jugé encore comme un état
de mort cérébral et que l'Allemagne
n'avait pas encore débloqué 100
milliards d'euros pour ces équipements
militaires à venir je vous remercie
merci pour cette grosse minute Philippe
Folliot
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
je ne vous parlerai pas aujourd'hui
des risques relatives et des éléments
que nous attendons par rapport
aux forces de souveraineté et à notre
stratégie ndopacifique que j'ai eu
l'occasion de juger à plusieurs reprises
comme quelque peu indigentes
de la même façon et je peux pas rebondir
sur ce qu'a dit notre collègue par
rapport à l'exercice Orion et sur notre
capacité à avoir une projection une
entrée en théâtre à maintenir et
certainement à développer moi je
voudrais vous parler de l'Ukraine et des
livraisons d'armes et de l'impériose
nécessité de soutenir maintenant
fortement et rapidement les Ukrainiens
concrètement monsieur le ministre
combien d'amix 10 RC avant de nous
livrer
parce que on sait très bien que comme
cet équipement n'est pas opérable autant
que ceci nécessite une chaîne logistique
particulière et que en fonction du
nombre cela montre l'efficacité je veux
dire entre guillemets de
l'investissement qu'on va faire nos amis
Ukrainiens par rapport à cela ensuite
sur les systèmes de défense anti-aérien
et je pense à l'air eurocale et autres
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres perspectives
de livraison pour protéger les
infrastructures et les populations
civiles et un dernier question
nous avons
si d'après ce que nous avait dit le chef
d'état-major de l'armée de l'air 12
mirages 2016 qui sont actuellement
stockés qui étaient prêts à être vendu
est-ce que vous envisagez de pouvoir les
céder à l'Ukraine ou tout au moins dans
un premier temps de former des pilotes
pour que si la décision était prise
de les livrer donc
puissent avoir des des pilotes
Ukrainiens qui puissent les utiliser
merci
Philippe Rachid
merci président de questions rapides la
première c'est sur l'OTAN mais sur le
volet intégration de la Suède à la
Finlande parce qu'il y a encore quelques
difficultés donc peut-être un point
d'étape et de d'avancer notamment avec
pour la Suède le catcheur qui est le
fait que la Finlande est prête à faire
un avancée seule et les conséquences et
deuxième point moi j'ai envie de dire et
le Parlement parce que sur l'alpm c'est
vrai qu'il y a pas eu d'associations que
nous n'aurions souhaité nous sur la
préparation pareil sur la question
africaine puisque il y a effectivement
moi je partage sur le fait que il faut
être avec des états souvent en face de
nous et des constructions fermés pour le
coup il y a eu le discours hier du
président République et donc je pense
que c'est intéressant aussi moi je
souhaiterais président Cambon et on le
demandera de groupe qu'il y a un débat
en séance sur la question la France en
Afrique non pas la politique africaine
française en Afrique en tout cas il y a
une réflexion à avoir globale des uns
les autres on a beaucoup d'éléments à
évoquer également si le Parlement sur la
question adopacifique et j'y ajouterai
pour l'indopathique aussi également les
collectivités alors je sais bien que sur
la question la défense et de l'armée il
y a Hist je sais que le miss est très
attaché à cela la question gaullienne
des domaines réservés mais pour autant
pour autant rien n'interdit une lecture
à dire à moderniste pour les pour les
golians le golem je suis en tout cas et
donc je pense qu'il y a oui goliago
liste n'est pas une chose présente on
aura l'occasion d'avoir une discussion
si vous le souhaitez ce sont deux choses
totalement différentes et donc en tout
cas je pense qu'il est important en plus
sérieusement c'est vrai que monsieur le
ministre en tout cas sur ces trois
questions là soit sur LPM sur l'Afrique
et sur un opacifique je crois qu'il y a
il y a un manque en tout cas
d'intégration du Parlement en amont en
amont dans la dans la construction dans
la réflexion avant même que on puisse
avoir des des projets de loi de cas
échéant
merci Rachid Joel guerrier
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
moi aussi je voudrais vous exhorter sur
l'Ukraine elle est vite c'est essentiel
mais je ne répéterai pas tout ce qui est
dit partout à ce sujet mais c'est
vraiment extrêmement important
j'aimerais savoir s'il y a un calendrier
peut-être autre chose président Cambon a
parlé du nouveau pôle d'influence
Varsovie il est essentiel bien sûr de
nous impliquer davantage au sein de
l'OTAN je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est
indispensable tant vis-à-vis des pays
d'Europe du 113 que des états balles
nous avons vraiment un rôle extrêmement
important à jouer une petite question
est-il vrai que notre armée de l'air est
prête à les former des pilotes à
Varsovie des pilotes Ukrainiens Varsovie
c'est une information qui m'a été donnée
j'aimerais pouvoir la vérifier et
ensuite vous avez parlé de la nécessité
du partage populaire du portage
populaire pour l'acceptabilité de ses
413 milliards d'euros des forces de
défense alors vous avez dit que vous en
parleriez plus tard vous avez répondu
une question sur le SNU moi j'aimerais
quand même en savoir un tout petit peu
plus sur au sein de la réserve
l'importance de la réserve citoyenne
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de vous en
parler quand vous aviez reçu notre
bureau au ministère ça me paraît
absolument indispensable de même que les
journées défenses et citoyenneté je vous
l'avais dit elles avaient été supprimées
à l'étrange journée en train de les
remettre en place est-ce qu'il y a un
peu de nouveau à ce sujet parce que ça
me paraît vraiment encore une fois
essentiel merci
merci Joël Nicole Duranton merci
monsieur le Président mais mes questions
ont déjà été posées par mes collègues
notamment sur Orion
Gisèle Jourdain
moi monsieur le ministre je souhaiterais
donc que vous évoquez par rapport donc à
la question de la fidélisation donc les
efforts que va consentir cette future
lait elle l'EPM au plan famille auquel
nos militaires sont très attachés je
crois que justement un moment où
les choses changent l'environnement vous
l'avez dit donc ce modifie mais il
n'empêche que pour le vécu donc des
familles et la fidélisation au sein donc
de nos armées c'est extrêmement
important et je crois que ce n'est pas
c'est loin d'être donc un gadget et je
crois que ça rassurerait énormément que
de voir comment on peut avancer sur ces
sujets là qui permettraient de conforter
parce que la piste des réserves c'est
très bien moi j'y suis très sensible
avec Jean-Marie bauquel nous avions
d'ailleurs commis un des rapports assez
conséquents sur donc le les réserves
d'ailleurs tu en avais combien avant
nous avec notre ami Michel bouton nous y
sommes très attachés dans cette
commission mais avant tout c'est quand
même le vécu donc de nos militaires au
sein donc des casernes puisqu'on a
évolué vers cette armée aujourd'hui de
métier puisqu'on a plus une armée de
conscription c'est important c'est pour
vous pouvez nous en dire un tout petit
peu plus merci beaucoup
mondiale on voit qu'un dictateur n'est
pas sensible aux paroles ni sensible
qu'aux actes et résistance pourquoi je
dis ça ça rejoint le problème des avions
je te demande monsieur le ministre son
sentiment par rapport à la conduite
psychologique d'une guerre parce
qu'actuellement il y a deux attitudes
les Américains et les Allemands parlant
des avions ou autres après avoir dit
pareil pour les chars non on va pas
faire ça on va pas faire ça présente la
ville française a été beaucoup plus
lancée rien n'est exclue parce que je
trouve personne à dommage de dire déjà
l'adversaire ça je le ferai pas ça je le
ferai pas il ne devrait y avoir qu'une
impossibilité c'est le nucléaire sauf
riposte mais sur les autres armes on a
rien à dire psychologique
on termine en beauté avec Jean-Marc de
Skinny le président non pour la retraite
je reviens sur sur l'OTAN de chez le
ministre aujourd'hui tous les membres de
l'Alliance
considère que c'est le parapluie
américain qui les protégera d'où les
difficultés peut-être pour avancer sur
l'ordre de la défense mais mon problème
n'est pas là malgré les difficultés avec
les Turcs et la Hongrie peut-être que
vous pourrez nous dire ce que vous en
pensez mais le président de la
République avait dit l'OTAN c'est en se
fait le RAM plat j'étais d'accord avec
lui à l'époque c'est clair
qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas vous
avez cité tout à l'heure la
réorientation de nos en Roumanie donc on
assume on assure on rentre dans les
commandements de l'OTAN je suppose et on
aura une part importante à assumer puis
sur des problèmes de
un pays important au niveau de cette
alliance mais le problème c'est
nos concitoyens est-ce qu'il ne faut pas
le réexpliquer et comment vous pouvez
vous y prendre pour leur expliquer
qu'aujourd'hui c'est comme ça c'est la
grande stabilité en Europe et la
sécurité en Europe c'est bien l'Alliance
atlantique moi j'ai fait une interview
là je me fais traiter par les gens
d'extrême gauche ou d'extrême droite
aussi de salle comment
au bout de l'impérialisme bien sûr je
montrais mon voisin là tout à l'heure ce
qui est arrivé ici d'accord il m'a dit
bon mais comment expliquer à nos
concitoyens que c'est la stabilité la
sécurité en Europe et je pense que là il
faut prendre une initiative bien sûr pas
que vous mais c'est il faut que le
gouvernement réfléchisse à cela parce
que je crois pas que ça soit à travers
le salut que vous ferez passer ce
message là nos concitoyens aujourd'hui
ils sont pas prêts à entendre que l'OTAN
c'est l'élevage de sécurité pour nous
quoi quand je dis donc concitoyens c'est
la grande majorité on a trop
contesté l'appartenance à l'OTAN et au
jour d'aujourd'hui on peut pas changer
de pied on est bien obligé de participer
d'y participer activement
merci voilà Monsieur le Ministre
quelques questions merci beaucoup
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs j'ai envie de faire des
réponses minutes mais c'est moins gagné
déjà vu les thèmes qui sont qui sont les
horaires évoqué on va les tenir les
horaires
peut-être que sur la question de Wagner
en Afrique je réserve cette réponse
peut-être un format où on ne serait pas
capté je pense que c'est pas permettra
de faire une réponse plus complète que
ce qui peut être dit ça me semble sage
merci monsieur le Président rusticité
masse technologies remontée de terrain
avez-vous dit vous avez bien raison
début de la guerre en Ukraine je
reviendrai sur l'Ukraine dans un instant
drone Chailly d'iranien dizaine de
milliers d'euros de coupe pièces avec
quoi vous le détruisez un missile de
défense solaire qui peut coûter
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
voire plus d'un million d'euros bon ben
voilà cet exemple de remontée de terrain
est concret c'est la masse mais c'est
que la masse c'est aussi évidemment le
rapport au coût et donc c'est ce qui
s'insérise aussi à l'Arsenal et donc ça
dans les travaux que nous menons
économie de guerre mais aussi des
travaux plus globaux de la LPM il est
clair que ce sujet doit être traité
c'est vrai pour les munitions téléopérée
les munitions
quand on dit drone on met tout et
n'importe quoi dans le mot drone puisque
du petit dessin de drone jetable pardon
de cette expression mais pour être
compris et grand public à un drone
beaucoup plus tactique armé
réutilisables qui peut avoir plusieurs
années durée de vie on parle évidemment
pas de la même chose donc là je pense
que dans on parlait d'un rapport annexé
précis je pense que là typiquement les
tableaux sont indigestes mais je mérite
d'être scientifiquement exact enfin en
tout cas scientifiquement ils sont ils
ont une maladie d'exister numériquement
pardonnez-moi c'est il est clair qu'il
va falloir qu'on soit capable de
commencer à expliquer nos concitoyens au
fond qu'est-ce qui relève des drones qui
rentrent dans un arsenal
fixe en quelque sorte figé enfin figé
la tricion malheureusement au combat est
possible et qu'est-ce qui relève
évidemment de ce qu'on pourrait appeler
une munition c'est jetable voilà ça
c'est typiquement une quelque chose de
d'absolument clé monsieur le sénateur
Jul sur Orient bon Orion décidé en 2021
la planification a largement été reprise
depuis février dernier on l'a musclé
Orion
j'aurai l'occasion avec l'échelle
d'état-major peut-être vous présenter
les le bilan d'Orion lorsque
l'entraînement sera terminé c'est le
plus grand entraînement
qui alors normalement vous sera convié
normalement vous l'êtes mais après vous
l'êtes voilà ça y est
vous l'êtes en tout cas tous les tous
les parlementaires des moments où on
puisse quand même tous les
parlementaires des départements
concernés en seulement été invités mais
aussi associé en amont pour aussi
l'explication grand public évidemment
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens les maires
ont d'ailleurs été tous aussi consultés
et concertés en tout cas s'il y a des
parlementaires qui veulent mais comme
pour tous les sujets concernent les
armées je suis évidemment votre
disposition bon Orion c'est le plus
grand exercice 1 TER armée de l'armée
française depuis des décennies quand je
dis depuis des décennies c'est avant ma
naissance ces clés notre capacité à
stresser évidemment le modèle certains
sont revenus sur des capacités certains
follow dans l'introduction de son propos
sur les capacités de projection
typiquement Orion là c'est pas une
affaire de cours budgétaire c'est pas
une affaire de tableau c'est une
capacité à stresser en grandeur nature
un certain nombre de modélisations et de
planification de l'opération donc là
pour nous c'est clé oui je réponds à
votre question évidemment nos alliés de
l'OTAN sont informés d'une part associer
d'autre part certains pays ont même un
rôle dans l'exercice et évidemment on en
tire un certain nombre de conclusions
qu'on partagera avec les différents
alliés sakure le général qui évidemment
s'occupe de ses affaires au sein de
l'OTAN évidemment est associé avec
l'ensemble du système de planification
qui va bien je reviendrai sur le temps
dans un instant sur l'Allemagne pardon
monsieur le sénateur si le président est
d'accord moi je
cette heure là je suis coupé plaisant
allons-y président est-ce que je peux
poser bien sûr ce qui m'a un peu
interpellé en découvrant cela à la télé
puisque nous n'avions pas été informés
nous n'avions pas été informés donc je
regardais ça à la télé c'est la distance
extrême qu'il y a entre la puissance de
cet exercice militaire et
la totale
non implication réelle de nos
concitoyens alors quand on compare ça à
ce qu'il vient de se faire en Ukraine
rapport que nous faisons ou barcan
puisqu'on travaille dessus on n'a pas
terminé comment ou pensez-vous qu'il ne
serait pas nécessaire à un moment donné
d'associer ce que j'appelle peut-être en
mauvais termes la sécurité
civile pour que
il y a une participation active et pas
on n'est pas au showbiz quand les balles
sont réelles quand l'ennemi est réel
voilà j'ai cette interrogation
plusieurs choses un déjà comme je vous
dis l'exercice il est quasiment
historique puisqu'il n'a pas eu depuis
très longtemps alors il est public il
est dans l'atmosphère depuis plus d'un
an bien avant mon arrivée d'ailleurs
après peut-être que tout ça est passé
inaperçu
l'état civil est largement associé à
l'exercice dans les départements
concernés quand je dis l'état civil
préfecture sécurité civile force de
sécurité intérieure parfois les
collectivités territoriales concernées
pour le coup c'est association est faite
après voilà planification de l'exercice
il est clair que il est tellement inédit
cet exercice que il se suffit déjà à
lui-même pour stresser notre modèle
d'armée en tant que tel ça c'est aussi
une décision qui a été prise par
l'état-major c'est de se dire qui
embrasse trop mal étreint si on fait un
exercice beaucoup trop large on en
tirera pas non plus les conclusions
opérationnelles déjà du côté midi pour
dire les choses très directement qu'il
faille ensuite aller davantage chercher
la résilience de l'ensemble de la nation
sur ce sujet outre-mer compris
d'ailleurs c'est indispensable mais là
aussi je pense que dans les bilans et de
retour d'expérience certaines opérations
ici ou là sont faites en association on
pourra vous rendre compte sur cette
affaire là mais de fait moi je partage
l'ambition à terme d'aller de plus en
plus loin dans notre capacité à et je
pense les élus locaux ont un rôle majeur
à jouer dans cette affaire c'est aussi
pour savoir que les correspondants en
défense au sein de chaque conseil
municipal j'entends leur donner petit à
petit un rôle et un qu'on a un devoir
d'information vis-à-vis d'eux enfin je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup de choses
toutes simples la résa fitoyenne aussi
d'ailleurs est un des outils qui
permettra de le faire en tout cas je
pense qu'il faut qu'on aille plus avant
en la matière sur le volet achat de
matériel d'armement j'ai déjà en partie
répondu le ministre te dis a dit au fond
c'est ces pays sont sous parapluie
nucléaire américain je pense qu'il faut
le redire aussi vous avez bien fait de
le dire parce que la réalité c'est que
plus on se déplace et vous êtes
dessinateurs qui vous déployez beaucoup
sur le terrain plus on se déplace dans
les pays à l'est de l'Europe ou dans le
centre de l'Europe plus les opinions
publiques ne sont pas inquiète mais
elles ont peur de ce qui se passe parce
que il se trouve que notre opinion
publique est inquiète mais je ne peux
pas dire qu'elle ait peur comme les
opinions publiques du centre de l'Europe
peuvent avoir peur c'est le bon sens qui
parle c'est le bon sens de la proximité
géographique du théâtre et de la Russie
c'est aussi le fait que inconsciemment
une partie de notre population a
intégrer aussi une dissuasion nucléaire
à certains égards bon et ça il est clair
que lorsqu'on est allemand et ben le
ministre a raison c'est depuis toujours
la promesse aussi du parapluie nucléaire
américain pourquoi F35 pourquoi l'achat
de
pas un scoop parce que je dis mais je
pense qu'on ne le dit pas assez nous
pour expliquer ce qui se passe pourquoi
les Allemands achètent un avion de
chasse américain parce que c'est tout
simplement la bombe américaine qu'il
s'agit d'emmener voilà pourquoi rafale
parce que c'est pas une bombe française
que les chasseurs vont devoir emmener et
donc de fait cette vérité c'est pas un
scoop enfin je le redis parce que ça
explique que si beaucoup de choses et
d'ailleurs très sincèrement le autorité
politique allemande vous disent il y a
le court terme sur étagère la nécessité
du parapluie et il y a le long terme
dans lequel de bonne foi je le crois
vraiment et les politiques allemands
dissocient cette affaire en disant pour
autant pour des raisons industriels on
veut avoir notre propre avion aussi ou
pour des raisons militaires l'avenir le
dira en tout cas ça dépendra aussi des
sensibilités politiques et ça dépendra
aussi du fonctionnement des coalitions
puisque pour le coup là aussi tout ça
fonctionne pas complètement comme chez
nous il faut aussi le redire donc avec
avec nos lunettes monsieur sénateur
Folliot sur l'un d'opacifique alors
indigente je vous trouve dur sur le
volet militaire en tout cas la copie qui
va sortir de la LPM va quand même
constituer un bon en avant important
s'il y a 10 ou 15 ans
il y a 10 ou 15 ans une opération comme
pitch black n'aurait pas été possible
voilà il y a 10 ou 15 ans une opération
comme celle qu'on a conduite avec le
sous-marin nucléaire d'attaque
l'émeraude n'aurait pas été possible il
y a 10 ou 15 ans les opérations en
commun avec l'Australie pour cause
n'étaient pas possible donc je vous
avais raison de dire que l'ambition est
forte et parfois le résultat est trop
timide ça je comprends indigent je
trouve ça dur par rapport à ce que les
armées ont fait comme effort c'est
quelques dernières années mais je je
sais que par ailleurs vous êtes
militante cette affaire et que vous
attendez beaucoup et je comprends que
vous attendiez beaucoup néanmoins sur
l'Ukraine
amx-10rc je ne communique pas le nombre
publiquement parce que les chiffres qui
ont circulé d'ailleurs aussi où là sont
des chiffres qui sont qui sont faux je
tiens à dire que là où mais vous en
venez du théâtre ukrainien là où nous
notre partenaire ukrainien nous attend
de manière très pressante et je les
comprends c'est sur deux segments
l'artillerie sur lequel on a fait nos
preuves alors TF1 compris d'ailleurs
même si c'est l'ancienne génération
César César matériel nouveau César
entretient du matériel déjà donné César
pièces détachées César aubus César
carburant toute la galaxie et ses
informations pardonnez-moi toute la
galaxie du sujet artillerie qui est
absolument clé sur lequel avec le
président de la République on a le fait
le choix évidemment de de se mettre mais
assez naturellement les performances
françaises étant ce qu'elles sont voilà
je rajouterai les léru puisque là aussi
ce sont quand même des armes
redoutablement efficaces qui ont été
donnés au mois de décembre dernier et
qui par définition aussi trouve toute sa
place sur sur le théâtre la deuxième des
choses c'est la défense solaire ou mal
interrogé sur le sujet alors cretal
l'enjeu c'est pas tant le nombre de
systèmes que le nombre de missiles pour
armer les dispositifs crottables on a
des discussions avec ce nombre de
partenaires qui ont des missiles pour
pouvoir les donner à l'Ukraine je n'en
dis pas plus parce que tout ça n'est pas
complètement abouti les Ukrainiens sont
véritablement satisfaits du matériel qui
a été donné pratiquement tous les tirs
de crotale sont des tirs d'interception
réussie donc ça évidemment c'est c'est
quand même quelque chose d'important
sont des vies d'ailleurs qui sont sauvés
il faut le dire la défenseur vous le
savez mieux quiconque c'est pas que pour
protéger les intérêts civils ça permet
aussi de protéger le théâtre du champ de
bataille donc ça a aussi des vertus
importantes on le voit bien d'ailleurs
sur le comportement de l'aviation russe
me semble-t-il où on voit quand même la
défense solaire ukrainienne se durcir
petit à petit avec des effets induits
sur le comportement russe qui se qui se
constate et l'urgence pour moi et pour
nous italiens guidocrosetto monologue et
moi-même c'est de mettre suffisamment la
pression sur MBDA et sur Thalès pour que
le dispositif santé que l'équivalent un
peu des patriotes américains se livrait
le plus vite possible parce que la masse
pour le coup la couverture et
l'efficacité décidé de se dispositif et
clé j'ai rajouté M200 qui a été acheté
par le fond de soutien à teles donc là
pour le coup c'est les deux segments sur
lequel il faut avancer vite le troisième
segment sur lequel évidemment il y a des
conversations sur les avions des
discussions qui sont en cours présents
un public a dit il y a pas de tabou la
difficulté elle est évidemment
logistique et en matière de formation
elle est enfin l'avion c'est aussi ce
qui va avec au sol c'est évidemment la
capacité d'entretien mécanique tout ça
dans des horizons de temps qui sont par
définition absolument pas du court terme
on sait tous mais je ne m'engage pas oui
des discussions ont lieu avec les
Ukrainiens il y a pas de tabou sur ce
sujet comme il n'y a pas de tabou sur la
question de la formation non le
quatrième point sur lequel on a une
pression c'est sur les obus c'est sur
les munitions ça je crois que là pour le
coup c'est l'actualité pour l'ensemble
de l'Occident B ITD américaine compris
l'accès à la poudre c'est pour ça aussi
que j'ai pris un symptôme de décision
sur lequel je ne reviens pas mais la
capacité d'endurance
de l'armée ukrainienne qui fait face
avec courage elle est aussi dans cette
capacité à tenir sur le volet des
munitions et de l'entretien du matériel
on vient aussi aux questions qui ont été
abordées précédemment mais peut-être
monsieur le Président comment dans un
dans une commission peut-être dédiée non
captée on pourrait peut-être approfondir
certains sujets liés à l'aide à
l'Ukraine puisque là aussi de toute
façon c'est un sujet qui va s'imposer à
nous dans les semaines qui vont venir
monsieur le sénateur temal souhaite
Finlande vous avez raison de le redire
ces clés que ça se fasse le plus vite
possible et ensemble pour la diplomatie
française il est clair que cette affaire
puisse se faire sans tarder je le redis
ici c'est important
[Musique]
quand il y aura des décisions et qu'on
en saura plus pays par pays parce que
c'est aussi ça secoue construit avec le
partenaire ça c'est clé en revanche mais
je ne je ne suis pas encore sénateur je
savais peut-être Nicole du rentrée est
formidable donc non mais moi je vous
laisse Nicole Duranton formidable donc
je pense aussi qu'il est peut-être utile
que on multiplie les points de rencontre
et de discussion y compris avec les
parlements des États africains concernés
je pense que la diplomatie parlementaire
elle a du sens aussi on ne peut pas le
faire là je forme un vœu s'il te
présente comme bon my autorise je pense
que ça ne peut pas faire que par
l'exécutifs il y a aussi quand même des
enjeux qu'ils doivent se faire entre
chef militaire j'ai donné mandats au
Sénat au chef d'état-major des armées de
parler avec leurs homologues entre
diplomates c'est l'affaire Catherine
Colonna mais si emploi mais aussi entre
parlementaires et je pense qu'à nous
tous on peut aussi bâtir une stratégie
qui est assez originale et innovante
donc par définition il y a une part
évidemment de de construction qu'il faut
qu'il faut assumer après moi de manière
globale sur la dopacifique vous l'avez
dit plus il y aura de débats mais pas
qu'au Parlement à Paris sur les sujets
politiques géopolitiques mieux ce sera
et je suis quand même frappé de voir que
à la fois les chaînes info font leur
travail en traitant ces sujets mais
quand même temps on peut pas dire qu'on
soit saturé non plus par par bref je
vais me faire des amis je le sens mais
exactement exactement
non mais je l'ai vu et pour le coup ça
va vraiment dans le bon sens en tout cas
moi je peux pas vous dire mieux le fait
que votre serviteur est à la disposition
de votre commission pour approfondir les
sujets qui vous plaira sur l'Ukraine je
vais en partie sur le temps Madame la
Présidente alors dans le rapport
perrinte aux esquinies il y a des choses
courageuses sur sur le temps et le
ministre l'a dit en disant qu'il faut
qu'on arrive aussi à reprendre des
initiatives de pédagogie sur ce qu'est
le temps ce qu'est le rôle particulier
de la France dans le temps faut pas se
raconter d'histoires il y a une forme
aussi d'anti-américanisme primaire qui
fait dire d'ailleurs n'importe quoi à la
pensée gaulienne ou gaulliste pour le
coup et qui fait raconter n'importe quoi
sur la décision de 1966 du général de
Gaulle avec un à peu près que Madame Le
Pen entretient avec avec quand même
beaucoup de brio et donc ça c'est tout à
fait étonnant et je pense qu'il faut que
dans le combat politique on le conçoit
Atlantis ou pas Atlantis premièrement
américain en tout cas faut pas faire
dire n'importe quoi aux décisions
historiques que c'était prise puisque on
est sorti d'une intégration de l'OTAN un
moment donné avec des bases américaines
sur le territoire national pour des
raisons données et le président Nicolas
Sarkozy a repris une décision
d'intégration avec des conditions qui ne
sont pas paramétriquement
identiques à celle que le général de
Gaulle avait pris en 1966 donc je pense
qu'il faut qu'on refasse aussi tout
simplement un peu d'histoire et la
vérité ne s'emportera que mieux et oui
elle est mieux que ça quand on dit qu'on
revient dans l'intégration on ne revient
pas par exemple de l'intégration sur la
planification nucléaire qui est quand
même le cœur du cœur on garde une
autonomie sur notre propre dissuasion ce
qui d'ailleurs amène ce que vous disiez
monsieur le ministre sur le fait que les
pays d'Europe parfois ne comprennent pas
forcément ce que veut dire la dimension
européenne nous intéresse vitaux et
présent dans la République plusieurs
fois il est revenu publiquement en
disant à nous peut-être aussi de
l'expliquer davantage au pays qui nous
entourent sur ce que serait la ce que
sont cette dimension européenne de nos
intérêts de nos intérêts vitaux après
sur le rapport à l'OTAN de la France
je pense qu'il faut aussi que l'on
montre ce qu'on fait bon quatrième
contributeur sur le volet financier
c'est pas rien pour le fonctionnement
deuxième contributeur ce chiffre n'est
pas connu sur la contribution militaire
chaque année chaque pays fait une
promesse de mise à disposition moyen
militaire à l'OTAN il y a la promesse le
budget primitif en quelque sorte et elle
réalisait le contaministratif parlons de
cette comparaison sur ce qui est
véritablement mis à disposition et sur
ce qui est réalisé la France et le
deuxième contributeur après les
États-Unis car entre ce que nous
promettons en bateau en moyen en
état-major chaque année on dit voilà on
met à disposition de l'OTAN un certain
nombre de de moyens concrets nous sommes
le deuxième pays après les États-Unis
d'Amérique
sa personne le sait
faut dire aussi que le chiffre n'est pas
évident à trouver même pour moi donc tu
es heureux de le trouver et que ça dit
quelque chose qu'au fond ce qui est
promis est fait ça vaut ce que ça vaut
mais enfin ça à mon avis un peu de prix
troisième des choses il y a quand même
dans l'organigramme de l'Alliance
atlantique des Françaises des Français
qui comptent déjà votre
présidente de l'Assemblée parlementaire
pardon mais enfin ça compte s'active
donc quand même l'autre officier général
qui est en général un aviateur depuis
quelques années français général 5
étoiles la vigne qui évidemment un rôle
important en matière de prospective au
sein de au sein de l'OTAN le fait d'être
nationale en Roumanie qui est un des
plus grands pays avec la Pologne sur le
flanc oriental qui est nations cadre en
Pologne les Américains qui nations
Cameron Roumanie la France la capacité à
l'avoir fait vite et sans accroc est
quand même aussi un des éléments à des
caractères de la participation de la
France à l'OTAN et puis là pour le coup
je renverse l'argument
l'alliance de l'OTAN est aussi une
alliance nucléaire même si nous ne
sommes pas partis de la planification
nucléaire notre dissuasion nucléaire
participe je reprends les mots officiels
de la doctrine à la crédibilité globale
de l'OTAN donc je pense qu'on a des
choses à dire sur le rôle de la France
de l'OTAN mais il est clair que on a une
position singulière où on est jaloux
d'une autonomie stratégique que nous
revendiquons je crois d'ailleurs sur
l'ensemble des sensibilités politiques
représentées en tout cas ici au Sénat
l'Assemblée c'est moins vrai mais au
Sénat et donc là je pense que également
il peut y avoir un agenda aussi de de
reclarification en tout cas c'est
compliqué de faire une LPM si on n'est
pas au carré sur ce qu'on est en droit
d'attendre de l'OTAN de ce qu'on est en
droit de ne pas attendre de l'OTAN ça
repose aussi la question
parfois aussi du glissement que voudrais
certains partenaires ou alliés du notant
qui s'intéresserait davantage aux
Pacifique plutôt qu'à l'Atlantique Nord
et ça évidemment c'est aussi un des
sujets sur lesquels les parlements je
reviens sur ce que disait le sénateur
fait mal elle doit évidemment se
s'emparer de ce de ce sujet là sur la
réserve citoyenne je vois l'occasion d'y
revenir en présentant l'ensemble des
stratégies pour les réserves mais je
crois qu'il faut qu'on arrive à muscler
un peu cette réserve qui est utile mais
qui doit aussi faire preuve de
une forme de sobriété aussi et de voilà
puisque le parfois la distribution de
galons
a pu quand même créer quelques quelques
questionnements sur sur celle-ci donc
bon voilà je pense qu'il faut qu'on
fasse évidemment attention à ça
j'espère avoir répondu aux questions de
Nicole Duranton qu'elle n'a pas pu poser
parce que d'autres collègues l'avaient
fait mais en creux j'espère lui avoir
répondu madame la sellerie Jourda sur la
fidélisation j'aurai l'occasion d'y
revenir et de présenter le plan le plan
famille les clés évidemment il y a et
les sujets indemnités etc mais
indiciaire mais il est clair que la
question des familles c'est le ministère
dans la République qui a le plus de
mutations
en tout cas un des plus avec le
ministère de l'Intérieur il va sans dire
que c'est un impact sur les carrières
sur le moral et donc là et sur cette
déconjoints et des enfants donc là on y
revient sur ce que je vous avais annoncé
notamment en lien avec les collectivités
territoriales il y a un plan familial à
présenter et qui sera absolument clé
dans la capacité de garder sachant que
une approche par catégorie de grade
aussi évidemment vaut le coup d'être
affiné puisque
ceux qui sont en casernement c'est pas
pareil que ceux qui sont pas
occasionnement etc donc je crois que là
pour le coup il faudra faire des
propositions plus plus précises monsieur
casabone sur la conduite psychologique
ça me permet de continuer à répondre au
sénateur folio et sur ce qui a été dit
par ma présence sur sur l'Ukraine je
pense aussi qu'il faut pas trop céder au
mode médiatique je m'en suis agacé
publiquement
les médias nous ont emmenés au mois de
décembre sur la défense sol r puis tout
d'un coup elle a disparu des écrans
radars sans mauvais jeu de mots
puisqu'il n'a été question que des chars
au mois de janvier puis on parle plus du
tout des chars désormais le mois de
février a été consacré uniquement aux
avions et je vous forme le pari que le
mois de mars va être consacré aux obus
je pense que dans le fait aussi de
garder le soutien de notre population de
notre opinion publique dans le fait de
psychologiquement tenir collectivement
je pense que garder une forme et de se
briété parfois de discrétion mais aussi
de solidité dans notre manière d'aider
ne doit pas céder à toutes les modes que
le système politique ou médiatique nous
nous donne en tout cas surtout dans nos
enceintes dans lequel on a du recul sur
les choses et un peu de sagesse donc ça
pour le coup je pense que dans la fin en
tout cas votre réflexion qui me semble
très juste sur le caractère
psychologique de ce qui se passe
m'appelle à faire ce commentaire je
pense que il faut avoir le cap des
troupes et malheureusement avoir un
rapport au temps moyen au temps long sur
malheureusement ce conflit en Ukraine
puisque il peut il peut durer monsieur
le ministre je
parle plus nucléaire US j'ai répondu et
puis sur le temps oui j'ai répondu et
pareil pour les propos du président de
la République sur la mort cérébrale de
l'OTAN
il faut pas les dissocier à l'époque du
contexte la menace évidemment russe je
refais pour ceux qui nous écoutent la la
menace de russe n'était pas complètement
la même et je le redis aussi le
président de la République avait dit à
l'aune de difficulté que nous avions eu
en Méditerranée avec notre allié turc
donc ça s'inscrit dans un contexte qui
était bien précis parlons d'avoir été
long non non monsieur le ministre merci
de l'ensemble des précisions que vous
avez apporté à l'ensemble des orateurs
vous l'avez fait avec tous les éléments
que vous pouvez nous livrer comme vous
l'avez vu je pense que le Sénat et
singulièrement cette commission est très
avide de de pouvoir entrer dans le vif
du sujet de la LPM parce que les
circonstances l'imposent et c'est quand
même un texte qui est à la fois en
termes d'argent public et de décision
pour l'avenir nous paraît important
plusieurs d'entre vous et vous même
monsieur le ministre avait souligné la
dimension opinion publique je pense que
plus que jamais
il faut prendre en compte cette
nécessité de d'associer
l'opinion publique à la solidarité avec
l'Ukraine on avait vu quelques articles
de presse qui disent que déjà dans
quelques États européens le soutien est
un petit peu moins fort d'où la
suggestion que nous faisons
régulièrement de d'intéresser le
Parlement comme ça a été évoqué par un
des débats alors les débats sont ce
qu'ils sont mais enfin ils ont le mérite
quand même d'apporter un éclairage
et de faire porter la parole de celles
et ceux que nous représentons auprès du
gouvernement peut-être pour terminer
puisqu'on avait évoqué l'Ukraine on l'a
évoqué à travers différents prismes et
différents angles notamment ce matériel
etc mais ce que j'aimerais que vous
délivriez peut-être en
autrement si vous le souhaitez mais
comment voyez-vous quels sont les
renseignements que nous avons sur la
situation j'allais dire la situation
militaire en
Ukraine on voit à la fois on a plusieurs
éléments plusieurs informations
qui s'entrechoquent cette fameuse
offensive de printemps que l'on attend
des Russes qui sont auxquelles les
Ukrainiens semblent résister mais sur le
moyen long terme comment les choses sans
visage la mobilisation humaine très
importante du côté de la Russie les
fournitures d'armes certes qui
continuent mais est-ce que
[Musique]
on sait qu'on n'est pas du tout du tout
dans le temps de la négociation mais ce
que des renseignements que vous que vous
avez
quelle impression tirez-vous de la
situation aujourd'hui
on peut couper on peut couper
je suis désolé pour noter les
spectateurs mais il y a des éléments qui
mettent en jeu la sécurité de beaucoup
de monde donc tout le monde comprendra
que à la fois la Commission a besoin des
informer et que le ministre doit pouvoir
parler très librement sur ce sujet c'est
fait attendez on va prendre quelques
secondes en salon